earlier today we heard that Tucker
Carlson is out at Fox News and that his
last show was on Friday we're getting
new information that he was in fact
fired
unceremoniously without notification I
should say technically with notification
apparently they notified him 10 minutes
before making the information public so
they just hit him up and said you're out
your show's done you're not doing any
more bye-bye and it's shocking Fox News
basically just I don't know ended
themselves as especially as it pertains
to a younger demographic because Fox
news's aging demographic is well there
that it's just that their agent so they
definitely needed to capture young
people and they've lost it the news is
that Murdoch himself pushed for Tucker
Carlson to be removed so we got a bunch
of other shocking information of course
on uh I should say I don't know
inversely see we're upset about the
Tucker thing but we're really excited
for the Don Lemon thing Don Lemon also
got fired for apparently
um this is great I want to give a shout
out to our good friend Vivek ramaswamy
apparently when Don Lemon started
insulting him or you know arguing with
him on air that was the final straw for
terminating Don Lemon from CNN so uh
he's gone and then of course we have the
second marketing executive removed from
Anheuser-Busch placed on leave over the
Dylan Mulvaney Bud Light Bud Light
boycott uh scenario so this is this is
getting big we got news that apparently
Bud Light sails down for the for the
next week Bud Light sales were down for
the next week about 17 to 21 depending
which metric you use which is massive
and they're reeling from it and I would
say it's a bit worrisome Don Mulvaney
has not posted anything online in about
three weeks so I hope I hope the people
who care about Dylan are are looking out
for him and making sure you know
everything's okay because it seems like
this person is in desperate need of some
family care or or people to to be there
for them in this time I mean that
sincerely because it's got to be super
stressful not that I'm a fan of the work
that Mulvaney does but
you know let's let's just try and be
human for a minute and and win a boycott
while making sure that's as far as it
goes right so before we get started my
friends head over to castbrew.com and
purchase our coffee to support our show
that's right we've launched our own
coffee brand you can get rise with
Roberto Jr our rooster breakfast blend
and our Appalachian nights dark roast
which are both available available for
pre-order right now should be shipping
out soon about the latest it's May 5th
is when they'll be shipped to you and
then we'll have them in in regular stock
and we're gonna we're going to even
launch a subscription coffee service
with new products rolling out probably
every couple of weeks also don't forget
to go to timcast.com click that join us
button become a member so you can hang
out in our Discord server with
like-minded individuals and you'll get
access to our uncensored members only
show Monday through Thursday at 11 PM
and if you sign up at the 25 per month
level or you're a member for at least
six months you can submit questions and
potentially be one of our callers we
take about 4 four or five every night
you can call into the show and actually
ask us questions now before we uh uh uh
so so let me slow down smash the like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight
one of several guests is of course the
lovely Savannah Hernandez thank you so
much for having me Tim what's up guys
Savannah Hernandez here reporter
political commentator contributor for
Turning Point USA very excited to be
here
right on thanks for hangout and of
course I mentioned we have a special
guest who has been patiently waiting I
am excited to announce to all of you
that we are seeing that we have on the
show tonight ladies and gentlemen
Sheamus Coughlin you're a bad friend
what are you doing Mom you brought me on
this show on my special day and you
tease a special guest so people see you
it's Tucker Carlson no all the comments
on Twitter Bros like a stalker going to
be up that's not fair I'm literally
getting D I was getting Chats on my live
stream earlier today where people going
they think Tucker is going to be on Tim
cast hey what do you think about that
I'm I am actually mad at Tucker you're a
dirty dog no because I don't know
rationalization I said all last week you
were coming back it's true I was very
excited that guy Sheamus is coming back
he'll be back by Sunday and then you
know we're getting ready for the show
and I'm going to be tweeting out Sheamus
here and then once that's why he quit
1.1 million tweets about Tucker Carlson
and I'm like but my special guest is
Sheamus that's right he's my special
guest people aren't as excited as they
should be no they are they are it's
excited about me than they would first
like it's just not fair to give people
the expectation that Tucker's going to
be on and have somebody even cooler you
know what I mean we love Tucker but it
was either going to be one of two things
Tim was like you should just do your
Tucker impression I was like I don't
want that that's not true I don't want
people to think I am playing into your
shame games of making the audience think
a much bigger message to do that quite
frankly to say Tucker Carlson isn't on
or is on when he isn't is in fact
offensive to your audience and so I I
felt that it was very insulting I just
want the audience to know that I love
and care for you all and I think what
Tim did to you and did to me tonight was
just disgraceful was just disgraceful
and hurtful and I think you owe us an
apology
what
ladies and gentlemen I am terribly sorry
I brought Sheamus cockline thank you
that's all we ask for that's sorry that
you said that's literally
four
yeah I will say this people thought
Tucker was on do you think Tim would
have a big guess like that on and not
spend the entire day promoting like guys
Tucker's gonna be there the only reason
like the only reason I'd hide the name
is if I was ashamed he would literally
rename the podcast Tucker like it would
just literally be his new name on
YouTube your name like Tucker's show IRL
uh thanks for hanging out Sheamus yeah
happy to be here we also have had a
clear primolo oh hey I'm Hannah Claire
Brimley I'm a writer for timcast.com I'm
filling in for Ian tonight I'm sorry
Tucker upstage your big moment guys uh
this is a reunion oh it's not waiting
for in all seriousness it's Ripper
Mark's fault for doing this too tough
that's why he did it that's why he did
it he knew I was back on shimcast that
I'm a threat to the establishment so
they don't want my platform to continue
to grow rumble.com shamer that's my
that's my podcast that's my podcast
shamer yeah uh that explains it we're
bringing Shane back well sir just
pressing the buttons what's up guys
let's do this I will say real quick
though we definitely reached out uh
because we were like now that Tucker's
not doing the 8 PM slot on Fox News he
is free up but I'm sure everyone and
their grandmothers and their
grandchildren were calling Tucker
Carlson trying to get him on their show
so I do know that uh like we know a
bunch of the same people and we know
people who work for Tucker I'm hoping
that we can actually get him on the show
The Amazing I'm a big fan I think it'd
be fantastic but we'll see I mean it was
a last minute thing we reached out to
his people they said uh uh they let him
know but there's currently like a big he
got so let's jump into the news so you
can understand the context here this is
uh this is really interesting we have
the story from timcast.com
Fox News founder Rupert Murdoch pushed
for Tucker Carlson's ousting Murdoch was
reportedly cornered over the former Fox
News hosts oh I'm sorry concerned what
am I doing Murdoch was reportedly
concerned over the former Fox News
House's coverage of the capital Riot on
January 6th
Murdoch uh the former Fox News host
departures allegedly related to a
discrimination lawsuit filed last month
by former producer Abby grossberg
Carlson senior executive producer Justin
Wells has also been let go the Fox News
Representatives did not further comment
grossberg who worked on Sunday morning
features with Maria butter Romo claims
she was bullied and subjected to
anti-semitic comments after being placed
on Tucker Carlson tonight Carlson
previously reported on the capital Riot
noting Ray Epps who was president of the
capital on January 6 may be a government
informant ABS has since claimed he has
been scrutinized and received death
threats following Carlson's reporting
the FBI reportedly told 60 Minutes Epps
has never worked for the agency for the
LA Times I think um
I don't know I don't know exactly what
they said but I think the FBI statement
of 16 minutes was like Weasley weasel
words like the question is was he
informing for you or taking any
instruction from you and they gave this
he has never been an employee was this
one Ted Cruz was asking questions
oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry yeah but uh
so here's what what may be a factor here
they're saying January 6th coverage I
think specifically it's possible this is
somewhat related to the Dominion lawsuit
not directly indirectly in that they're
like we don't want to get sued again
don't go around accusing people of being
Federal informants or or things like
that that may be a factor in Tucker
Carlson's ousting but I do think it's
important to point out let's read this
headline from The Daily Mail Tucker
Carlson blindsided by Fox News firing
that was a direct order from Rupert
Murdoch after January 6 conspiracy
claims and producers lawsuit alleged
bullying sexism and anti-Semitism and
his exit erases 500 million in value I
think it's a I think it went up to a
billion from on their stock yeah so I
mean the important thing to point out is
that um uh Tucker was our only real
competition and with his ousting timcast
IRL we're going to the Moon maybe that's
why I came back I wasn't going to come
here I was telling Tim I would be here
and I wanted to leave him high and dry
but then once Tucker got fired I was
like this is opportunity that's right he
Sheamus is like bro I can literally do
my impression of him all the time and
people won't even know the difference
well now he doesn't want you to know
this but you can just watch timcast if
you want to see Tucker actually it's
better than AI exactly exactly
I do feel like this has the vibe of
McDonald's uh deciding that it's not
going to sell the Big Mac anymore
because some people get sick from it
like they have lost so much money Tucker
Carlson has such a big following how can
they possibly fill this void now dude
honestly you know again the reason why
he may or may not have been fired aside
I think that this is incredible for
Tucker Carlson and for Independent Media
as a whole to be quite honest for you
because we already all knew that cable
news was dead gen Z the average human
being is not getting their news uh you
know from mainstream media anymore to be
quite honest with you it's all coming
from Twitter I mean I've only ever
watched Tucker Carlson segments on
Twitter to be quite honest with you so I
really don't think that this is going to
impact him very much if he's only going
to get bigger we all know that and uh
yeah good luck to Fox News after this
because they just completely destroyed
themselves I hope you're right I don't
know that I'm so optimistic I think
you're right about Fox News destroying
themselves but part of what concerns me
is that there are millions of people in
this country who still believe believe
that the dominant media culture has any
credibility and they really do believe
that Fox News sets the standard for
acceptable conservative discourse and
with Tucker Carlson leaving well I do
agree he certainly doesn't need Fox to
stay afloat I'll still watch him you'll
still watch him the young audience who
likes him will his legitimacy isn't
going to be given or his uh ideas aren't
going to appear to have the same
legitimacy to an older audience I mean
it makes me wonder if he'll go
completely independent or if he'll move
to like Newsmax right because there are
President yeah I mean that would be even
more fun here's the thing I hope you're
right I hope you're right and Tucker
just continues to grow and blow up the
thing that people don't realize right
with Fox News as they exist is while CNN
is the network that tells you what
you're supposed to believe Fox is the
network that tells you what you're
allowed to believe you might not like
the flavor CNN is offering and so here's
the outer limit over here of what you're
allowed to voice and believe in what
Tucker Carlson did is he moved the
Overton window they had there more
towards the direction of
anti-establishment true truth speaking
as opposed to catering to the vision of
what conservatives should be that the
establishment right has been trying to
promote for decades well yeah a fox like
Hannity is you know he's the guy who
says the the the big things that control
stuff are bad so you should just sit
there and and listen to me yell about it
so that they can keep doing whatever
they want and then Tucker Carlson is
like you know actually they shouldn't be
doing that and here's an alternate
Theory this is one thing that
conservatives really struggled with in
media is what fox will do and what a lot
of these right-wing pundits will do is
they will poke holes in the media
narrative but they won't offer a counter
narrative and so when we have Tucker
Carlson talking about January 6th and
Ray apps what he's essentially doing is
filling in the gaps for people he's
saying here's this guy who we saw
inciting arguably allegedly right we
have the footage of it that's not
alleged but whether that's something he
would be prosecuted with inciting
violence for is another story however
what a traditional Fox News host might
say is we'll look at all of these holes
in the left's narrative but they
wouldn't say here's the alternate
explanation and in fact they would say
anyone who promotes that alternate
explanation is a far-right lunatic and
I'm not one of those guys Tucker Carlson
was actually willing to give you
substance aside from the left is wrong
agreed yeah I think he did bring forward
a lot of topics and like you said points
that we would not have normally heard
from a Hannity maybe even from olora
Ingram a lot of people talking about too
how Jesse Waters maybe the only last
person at Fox News that people could
really trust who could maybe even follow
Tucker Carlson so yeah you know this is
going to be a big hit like you said to
the older generation that does still
look to the mainstream media and view
them as a legitimate source of news
um we'll see what happens in the future
but you know like I said I think that
this is actually a good thing I'm look
I'm trying to look at the positives of
this you know what I mean just with like
uh Tucker leaving fox now we know the
corporate media is a laughing stock
nobody trusts them Elon is taking over
Twitter now independent journalism is
really thriving uh so yeah I've been
black pilled about a lot in the nation
and so I think that you know I'm just
I'm excited about where we're at in
regards to Independent journalism and
the freedom that people now have to be
able to tell the truth a little bit a
little bit more take a look at the story
from Politico it's interesting Tucker
Carlson's exit shows who who's the real
star at Fox no one is irreplaceable and
they they want to make the stupidest
argument I've ever heard that Glenn Beck
wasn't the star in 2009 when he
generated the largest viewership in the
5 PM hour Bill O'Reilly wasn't blah blah
blah they're arguing that fox will
easily replace Tucker Carlson in the 8pm
slot and I gotta tell you they will not
no they've already they've already tried
doing um I can't remember what for what
show it was they had one slot recently
in the past year whatever where they
were doing rotating series of guest
hosts trying to figure out who would be
a good personality and it didn't go
anywhere Tucker Carlson
is the guy right yeah dude and even when
he's absent right there's no clear oh
when Tucker's out we definitely want
this this person and they haven't been
able to successfully audition somebody
to inherit the slot so now they fired
him they haven't even given him a
transition schedule to leave and they're
going to do what with it who are they
going to call up from the the the uh
From the Bench to to fix this that's
what I'm saying I feel like Tucker was
Top Dog he wasn't afraid to talk about
things and the great thing about Tucker
2 is that he would go and speak to and
platform the smaller independent
journalists who had substantial stories
I remember when I was at the uh 2022
NCAA Women's swimming Championship
Twitter had deleted the clip of the
first athlete that spoke out against
Leah Thomas uh it wasn't uh Riley Gaines
or the other athlete who had spoken out
but it was this young Virginia Tech
swimmer named Rose Tucker picked up her
interview he is the one that made that
you know really big Twitter ended up
censoring and deleting the clip but you
know that's just an example of how
Tucker has been at the Forefront of of
like helping the little man and helping
the average American and that's why he's
popular because your average mainstream
media head doesn't care about the uh you
know the actual American public they
don't care about what we are going
through in this country they care about
sharing their talking points uh Tucker
was the exact opposite of that and there
really is no other pundit that can
compare in the mainstream yeah and
that's also part of why I was saying
earlier I really do think this is bad
for us we've been deprived of something
Tucker having that platform on national
television and being able to tell the
story of these female athletes who have
been deprived of what they should have
had the opportunity to do because Leah
Thomas was competing in their Sports was
massive two voters 55 and up that that's
that's what we're losing
in addition to YouTube the way that the
younger audience people who are
interested in Tucker well exactly and
look at who the abiding Administration
is targeting right now it's gen Z with
all of these dumb tick talkers now and
it is this next Generation that is going
to be leading this country that is going
to be leading uh you know us into where
we're going to be going as a country
guess I articulated that horrible but
yeah that's why I'm like okay let's lose
the Boomer audience all right like we
need to be focusing on the younger
people and I think that uh Tucker has
that big phone and he can do that with
the amount of Independent Media we have
I certainly don't disagree that Tucker
is going to be fine on his own and I
hope that his audience is going to
continue to grow I am just a little bit
cautious and I'm a little bit skeptical
that he's going to be able to build the
kind of platform that we would like to
see him have given how hard big Tech
clamps down on anyone who speaks the
truth and I hope that's true and look
I'm on Rumble now too for my podcast I
think they're a great platform I hope
they're able to reach some kind of deal
I do like your optimism but I will still
say I think the American people were
deprived of something I think it's very
sad he was basically the only person on
cable television saying anything right
like you said the other news anchors
give you talking points this is a threat
to democracy or that was racist and
xenophobic they'll just regurgitate
these lines they've heard someone else
say and Tucker would say something can
you give me an example of something say
Hannity said in the past few months no I
can't give you an example of something
can anybody in the room I will look
because I'm not I'm not a boomer I don't
really watch cable television I'll tune
in every now and again but it's pretty
rare for me I get most of my information
from the internet and the sources I find
to be credible there I just want you to
know that you're insulting a lot of
Boomers in the chat listen listen no
offense to the good Boomers some of them
I assume are good people right but my
parents are in that generation my
parents are in that generation too and I
think Tucker Carlson did a fantastic
work when he was on Fox the Boomers gave
us Star Trek the Next Generation that's
also true it's fantastic that is true
give them that's like one of the very
few things that's like the only thing
then but even that was a spin-off of
something I mean Gene Roddenberry wasn't
a boomer right
that's that's a spin-off from the
original Star Trek from the 60s yeah so
and they made it better
there's a whole huge debate to have
there we're not gonna get the we're not
going to get into that controversial
territory here on timcast what if Fox
brings on Don Lemon now and he takes the
eight o'clock it actually the thing is
it wouldn't sound that different
University but Fox wouldn't sound that
different if they brought Don Lemon on
that's what bothers me they're all so
they're all saying the same thing
they're interchangeable we gotta mention
that dude was fired but first I want to
talk about this story can I just make
one more Point really quickly about this
so they're saying what you said hit the
nail on the head right they think Tucker
is going to be replaceable because
everyone else on television is all of
these other personalities are it is not
going to be easy to replace Tucker we
got another theory a couple theories as
to why Tucker Carlson was removed from
Fox News this story just from the other
day on post-millennial AOC demands Biden
admin regulate Tucker Carlson Fox News
due to incitement of violence uh I just
like to point something out um
how do you regulate incitement to
violence does anybody have a suggestion
you'd be in jail yes incitement of
violence is a federal felony and how do
we regulate for people who are
committing felonies we arrest them and
put them in jail AOC said on MSNBC to
jensaki that what Tucker Carlson is
doing is incitement to his incitement to
violence in the government should be
involved they should be regulating this
or whatever she's what they're doing is
the typical leftist weasel words where
she's of course implying that Tucker
Carlson should be arrested and charged
but then saying no of course I I mean
they they should stop hate speech or
something and it's like you accused
Tucker Carlson of committing a felony
incitement to violence that is I'm
pretty sure defamation per se meaning
it's so egregious to accuse someone of
committing a crime that it's much much
easier to overcome the burdens in time
view Sullivan Tucker Crossing is
probably just Sue AOC outright for
saying this I hope he does because there
are people who really incite violence
like Savannah
that's right yeah you know what no I I
really I really hope that he does though
because to be quite honest I am tired of
these leftist politicians who do
continue to incite people to violence we
can look at the lgbtq community antifa
black lives matter the list goes on and
on we can look you know at the FBI and
all the times they've entrapped
Americans and try to incite them to
violence let's go ahead and get into all
of that and we want we have AOC over
here talking to the Biden Administration
demanding them to take Tucker off of
there it's absolutely ridiculous you
know Chuck Schumer yeah that's what I'm
saying Chuck Schumer came forward too
because he was saying that uh you know
Tucker Carlson uh killed democracy it
was the destruction of democracy when he
came out and he showed the American
public more January 6th footage that the
j6 commission was withholding it's just
absolutely ridiculous to me and I'm so
tired of being run by criminals but
that's just where we're at in America in
2023 uh you know the left can go ahead
and incite violence against us all day
long but um Tucker Carlson can't go and
accurately report on uh his own show
elected oh sorry I was just gonna say
AOC doesn't see that this is an
endorsement of Tucker like
that this is their guy right because
there are people and you know it is a
little bit of partisanship anything else
C says is wrong and to be fair that's
not an entirely bad judgment but now
that she's saying he's like Vines they
know he's not they know that she as a
representation of the left establishment
is afraid of him it makes him even more
powerful especially to those who support
him well exactly you should say he's
such a threat that he needs to be
imprisoned he needs to be taken off the
air yeah and of course like you said
they accuse every single person who
disagrees with them of inciting violence
that's the new version of calling
somebody racist all it means is you have
said something that I disagree with the
term ends up losing all meaning etc etc
the other uh Theory as to why I Tucker
Carlson is removed so I got the idea
here is that AOC is saying he's
committing a crime there's been big
pressure you know so Ma I doubt that's
the reason but you know maybe but the
other big question is Tucker just moved
to Florida
it was reported by the New York Post the
New York Post deleted the article
because I guess I had revealing
information as to where he lived why
would he go down to Florida well
Florida's nice it's a good retirement
but he did so in the past week which to
some insinuates that he knew he was
about to leave Fox News so this could be
kind of like a retirement jenkuger of
the Young Turk said he believes that
Tucker Carlson was trying to get fired
on purpose because he intends to run for
president
several others are implying that he may
be Trump's vice presidential pick which
would be the smartest move that that
would would have been the smartest move
at any point ever except for the fact
that no one believed it possible because
Tucker was working at Fox News now that
Tucker Carlson is a free agent
Trump Carlson 2024 sounds extremely
plausible I would like that even better
if he had kept his residency in Maine
of Maine's very first anyone in the Oval
Office you know they'd have never had a
president they've never had a vice
president I think Maine deserves that
win and Tucker Carlson would have been
the best pick for it is that your main
concern
um
it wasn't just a pun it wasn't just upon
it was a legitimate question do you
spend a lot of time thinking about
someone coming for me because I'll just
say well someone from Illinois someone
from Cook County I'm hoping whoever's
elected is not from there any election
New England really needs to hold on
otherwise they're gonna have to merge
into one state to have any kind of
electoral power but in being serious I
think when people pick vice presidents
they do want to show that they are
representing a different part of the
country that's why we picked Pence
initially right we have this Brash New
Yorker and then we have this like
Evangelical uh standard republican from
the Midwest in some ways obviously we
know Tucker Carlson is not like he does
spend a lot of time in Maine but he's
not really from there it would represent
different parts of the company although
it would be East Coast dominance I think
it's
I think it would be an extremely
unorthodox move to pick a VP who's from
the same state that you are claiming
residency in although I will say I have
not been interested in following the
2024 like pre-election stuff so far I
feel like Trump's kind of bored me I'm
not gonna lie like the constant
bickering with DeSantis but Tucker being
involved like obviously it's not
confirmed that he's going to be VP but
him just being involved in you know the
speculation that this could now be a
thing has made 2024 a lot more exciting
a lot more exciting I would say yeah I
mean I I would love to see a trump
Carlson ticket yeah that'd be great yeah
yeah I mean a trump Carlson ticket could
be a very interesting thing I would I
mean how would that work Tucker is just
gonna Lobby DeSantis to be his VP picker
Tucker would run a campaign in the
primaries
oh I'm sorry not DeSantis my bad Trump
or you like talk to Trump and say like
oh make me Donald The Establishment
wants you to think I can't be your VP
pick I can't actually or does does
Tucker launch his own presidential
campaign
yeah yeah Trump that's what I think
Scott's trying to do I think that's why
he's like I have an exploratory
committee I'm thinking about running for
president being like Trump please notice
me I'd love to be VP then Trump me to
them and says don't run and we'll give
you a position or something like that we
will give you that's probably a lot of
what what it is for for all these people
who are running they just want Trump to
appoint them somewhere yeah yeah I could
see that but Tucker Carlson will be
legit yeah I think that makes a lot of
sense the thing is uh apparently before
Tucker moved to Florida he had met with
with Trump and I I think Marjory Taylor
green or something like that so the
speculation was that something's been in
the works for a minute
I wouldn't be surprised I feel like his
relationship with fox has been uh
strained for long enough you know not
everything as much as we uh appreciate
what he does there's it doesn't Gonna
Last Forever it wasn't sustainable long
term and I don't think either one of the
parties were entirely happy with uh the
dynamic between the two of them no I
mean look Fox is going to try to find
their new like bad boy too their new
anti-establishment guy and it's going to
be super crazy well exactly because
they're going to want to to be someone
with sort of the veneer of being trans
aggressive but who will never say the
kinds of things Tucker Carlson but the
fact that we can't name
is
that would be yeah yeah Dawn London
would be uh Trump's Kamala I mean we've
gotta we've got more news as to as to
why people think Tucker may have been
ousted took us out Jonathan uh kogan
says BlackRock increased position in Fox
Corporation fintel reports that
BlackRock has filed a 13 GA slash a form
with the SEC disclosing ownership of
45.74 million shares of fox corporation
which is they say it's an increase of
14.75 percent an increase in total
ownership of 2.7 percent do you think
this play day role in Carlson's
departure
I don't know I mean probably isn't
BlackRock like a principal ESG company
interesting I mean it certainly could be
a factor certainly could be a factor I
don't think they're in love with Tucker
Carlson and what he's saying and doing I
don't think any one in court he's the
only one on TV the only Corporation the
only Corporation he was earning money
for didn't even like him so
yeah has Tucker criticized BlackRock
before
I wouldn't be surprised yeah he he has
to have but I mean that's the thing
blackrock's the one company he's like
for years I like them four years Tucker
Carlson has had multiple segments
talking about BlackRock
yeah well see and the amount of things
that he's talked about from again
January 6th the FBI the doj all of the
corruption and that from the economy to
the Border it's like he was talking
about real substantial issues uh not the
distractions that the mainstream is
continuously pushing our way so it was
only a matter of time before he was
eventually taken off air because I mean
we we've all seen how powerful Tucker
segments were we've all seen you know
how much sway he had in the public uh
how much support he does have so yeah I
mean I wasn't even surprised when I saw
this to be quite honest
yeah it was only a matter of time right
he wasn't going to spend the rest of his
career there but I mean how old is he
he's in late 40s no he's older than that
I think he's the 50
yeah 53 years old I mean 53. oh wow I
love that that's the picture that comes
up when you Google them it's the exact
picture you think would come up it's
that it's the face the the face where
he's scratching his face
he's 53 he's not quite at retirement yet
but he is at be the VP age I guess it's
what retirement ain't about your age
it's about your bank account he's got a
big one you're gonna absolutely step out
if you wanted to there's I don't think
he wants to though but there's other
questions about whether or not he just
saw how much money was being made by
people who were independent and he
realized that Fox News was just taking
everything from him you know I could see
it I mean I'm gonna be like Tim pool No
One's Gonna be taking my cash for me as
much money is he making that's too much
how much money is Tim making no one
should have that much the government
needs to take that he he makes that much
to voice Dr fauci on freedom Tunes it's
ridiculous and I wonder how much uh Fox
News was trying to censor and suppress
what he was trying to discuss I wonder
how much that was going on behind the
scenes as well so yeah that is why again
you know the Independent Media is
um so enticing to so many people because
then you're not Tethered to anybody or
anything you have nobody lording over
you telling me what you can and cannot
say and you know people have been making
the meme all day Tucker Carlson
Unleashed with it which I think is a
spot on but what if he didn't even want
to talk about politics this whole time
and that's how Fox got he wants to be
like a man he's like actually if I if I
use my diamond ax and keep hitting this
I don't know that he really wants to
like get off the ground he's like here's
my video I say on why SpongeBob got bad
after the first 10 years he's playing
OverWatch I just think that Hearthstone
you know part of it isn't even about
retiring it's that the landscape I think
people are
I'm talking I'm just kidding uh ABC it's
so rude for interrupting me I think that
the landscape of American media and
politics has changed so dramatically
that you know no one who goes into media
right now knows exactly where their
career will be in 10 years and I think
that's always been true of talker
Carlson it would be surprising to me if
he hadn't seen some sort of writing on
the walls and been plotting an exit the
weirdest thing about this to me is that
it's so abrupt I I don't yeah I don't
know if it was it was apparently like he
got 10 minutes notice yeah but let's
look look well I know that we are all
sitting here somber and serious but we
have a very very similar story that will
allow us to laugh and that story is Don
Lemon says he was fired by CNN lemon
said he's stunned and learned the news
from his agent quote Don will forever be
a part of the CNN family we thank him
for his contributions over the past 17
years we wish him well and we'll be
cheering him on in his future endeavors
well I'll be cheering on his departure
so we're all cheering for something how
about that CNN after 17 years at CNN I
would have thought that someone in
management would have had the decency to
tell me directly at no time was I ever
given any indication that I would not be
able to continue to do the work that I
have loved at the network it is clear
that there are some larger issues at
play now I got to agree first James
O'Keefe then Don Lemon people are going
after very proud okay so what we are
concerned about James O'Keefe and Doug
Carlson we're actually happy with the
Don Lemon thing so uh it is strange
though in a lot of shake-up in media so
are you saying no one at CNN actually
told him apparently he's lying okay I
guess CNN well that's why he worked
there yeah can I just say that my
favorite part about his firing is that
he couldn't even accurately report on
his own firing come on John damn I mean
it's also interesting to me that we're
all like oh so Tucker's probably gonna
go independent whereas like we're like
what is he gonna do
what happened to Brian stelter that's
where Don lemon's going we just know he
is not going independent and partially
this like how could they do this to me
statement proves how much he wants to
stay with the machine it's just such a
clear uh contrast in the mentalities
right we have no hope for him would you
guys see Brian stelter on that uh he did
that interview who was that interview
with I think it was news news Nation or
something and he's like why were you
fired Brian and he's like I don't know I
really have no idea and everyone's like
really Brian you know you don't know
your boss explained exactly why he was
firing people and it's like your boss
comes out and says I'm going to fire
partisan actors who are activists and
not journalists Brian stouter you're
fired me I wonder why that happened
yeah how could you do this to me says
Brian no well that's Don Lemon is like I
can't believe this happened are you
kidding dude also you made Caitlyn
Collins cry it's been reported yeah I
mean part of it is this idea like
how could Senior Management not contact
me like maybe it's because they don't
want to talk to you because you're
difficult to deal with like that's why
they made your own agent tell you
because they didn't want to have a scene
in the building they didn't want to deal
with a call like it it yeah and
sometimes the person is like a maniac
that's a fair point and Don Lemon fits
that that you know profile rational what
are you talking about Tim you you answer
you you answer you hired canceled people
you should uh dude get your get your
other chair Jeremy boring posted
something like many people are asking
about daily wire making an offer to her
but wherever Tucker lands he'll be
successful and then he later posted many
people are asking about the daily wire
hiring Don Lemon I'm just kidding
nobody's asking that well that would be
an amazing though John Lemon goes to the
Daily wire right it's a sad State of
Affairs because basically everyone on
cable news is somebody who would never
have gotten a platform if they had to
build it up on their own you know let me
let me tell you that's an important
Point yeah and how much how much was
done lemon getting paid too much
been with a network for 17 years four
million wow uh let's see is is a salary
is estimated to be four million dollars
per year
I'm thinking about that right
nobody likes Don Lemon like even the
left doesn't like Don Lemon nobody
nobody likes him so now I'm starting to
feel bad for him Tim you're really going
in on this way it's okay he can just
move to San Francisco and get
reparations we'll be fine here's what
I'm thinking about what's we're talking
about what could this guy do now that
he's like lost his job he can't get a
job at a movie theater as a manager
right because they'd be like dude you're
Don Lemon like that's gonna cause issues
you're overqualified
get out no it is yeah yeah like high
profile individuals can't get regular
jobs for the most part because they're
just like you're a huge liability we
don't want the attention we don't want
the commotion and we don't believe that
you'd actually take the job and stick
with it so Don Lemon where could he
possibly go
I'm imagining what it would be like to
be Don Lemon and to be hanging out
semi-retired because you got fired at a
bar do you think people are gonna go to
Don Lemon and be like hey man I'm a big
fan sorry to hear what happened
no way so it depends on the kind of bar
I guess no I don't think I don't think
based on the way the left and the right
view down limit that there's any
circumstance where he shows up somewhere
and they're like wow Don Lemon I'm just
a big fan of your work they might be
like oh yeah you're Don Lemon how about
that you never go to the center left bar
down the
streets I know he's like he's like he's
like weirdo Pandoras to corporate test
yeah and people are going to be like ah
look it's Don Lemon get a job dude
that's what they're gonna do he's gonna
become a twitch streamer he's gonna be
biggest one I I think that would be an
amazing character Arc but also I think
he's gonna do what a lot of people who
kind of failed their way out of the uh
career they're in whether it be meteor
politics and he's gonna go to be going
to Academia he's just gonna become a
professor some college is going to be
like oh God lemon we will just give you
tenure right away and you can teach the
next generation of people and then we
get to tell like bring you out whenever
we're like look how fast he checks all
the Dei boxes as well so that's a good
point is this is the reason why as well
media is so dead because the next
generation of Journalism students are
being taught and indoctrinated by people
like Don Lemon and Brian stelter it's
truly incredible yeah it's not a great
system but it's the one that exists
that's where Liz Cheney is Cheney's
teaching uh what University of Virginia
anybody actually watch Don Lemon but but
he's a name people know so I I hear I I
think I agree with Hannah Claire that
some University will be like
bro we only hire people who don't know
anything what if CNN offered you four
million dollars a year to host the
morning show with Caitlin Collins uh I
would say that's far too much it's gonna
be a giant waste of money I'm gonna go
do it and then I would go in there and
on the first day I would say everything
that they no I mean I'd say with the yes
CNN reach out to me let's have a
conversation you can contact my people
but I mean it's a serious question do
you think yeah what are you are really
like what would I have CNN have a show
with me if I would explain I would like
explain to the the public why the sexual
Revolution is a farce in this country's
right Christian values and that would be
my morning show I'd be like this coffee
is terrible but you know what's even
worse just has been done to mankind John
money Alfred Kinsey I would turn the
first Morning Show and do a presentation
on Alfred Kinsey no but in all
seriousness if if CNN tried poaching a
anti-establishment or right-leaning
personality and the CEO is like look we
don't want to be partisan
should they do it right like would you
take a morning anchor position at CNN
absolutely not you liar no but I don't
know I'm not a money person and I uh CNN
is a laughing stock I'd be embarrassed
to work there to be quite honest with
you see I feel like shame is kind of
right to be like yes I'll take the money
and then I'll just continue to be myself
and they can fire me like if you have an
ironclad contract where it's like if you
want to fire me you have to pay me an
additional million dollars like no just
run it out for six weeks ready to go
there is because again I really do truly
feel like corporate media is dead so
going to CNN would just kill my career
just be pointless yeah you're picking me
not the carcass but you're still making
four million dollars all right I see
what you're saying that's what I'm
saying like you go into CNN you look at
the camera and you explain all of the
horrible things that the industrial
military complex is doing and the wars
they're pushing us into you explain to
them yeah and the fed you explain to
them the the farce of sexual Liberation
you explain to them what's happening to
these children and that mutilated by
doctors and then you lead a a segment
with a few moments of prayer silent
prayer exactly if and then they're like
all right now
if you want to reach the people most in
need actually going to CNN is
essentially a missionary trip
oh yeah you Tim you just asked me if I
would go to Nineveh for four million
dollars or whether I would go into the
belly of that whale I'm choosing the
whale you're better than me you're
better well Jonah did it first too yeah
so uh the other thing is I've actually
gotten a bunch of messages from people
and they were like your main competition
for 8 pm has been removed and it's like
I look for us stuck across from this
competition for Tucker Carlson we are
not competition you know what I mean
like the twitch has been past Tim this
is a lot of pressure on you I don't know
like announce you are the news
and then he says uh you just watched him
cast iron off no one yeah you should ask
Tucker to be your new co-host dude but I
think the the reason I was asking about
CNN is because Chris Licht is clearly
trying to fix the network I'm not sure
if it can be done because like if uh if
you bought a car and then like some guy
say it's Don Lemon went inside that car
and then defecated all over the seats
the nice leather seats that happened to
a friend of mine actually and then left
the car in the Sun for you know several
days to fester in the summer heat in Las
Vegas
and and then I knew the car was given
was bought by some guys like I'm gonna
clean this up you know I still wouldn't
want to ride in the car yeah you know
what I mean there's nothing you could
you could replace the inside and
everything I'm just like you don't want
to be in a car that Don Lemon sat in but
it's not that whole value people are
going to see you driving around in it
and they're gonna be like dude you're
driving around in that car full of crap
it's like we cleaned it man it's like
well I hope so he who humbles himself
what did you say you humbles himself
will be exalted if that's what CNN is I
would go there and I would spread the
truth and I would I would I would take
the embarrassment of being on CNN but
there's an important point to this
conversation which is that as we're
talking about CNN every single one of us
like that would be super embarrassing to
be honest I would be like absolutely
can I can I play for you the clip that
got Don Lemon fired so this is from
Aaron rupar the notorious uh was he
still with Vox I don't know where he
works uh I guess not he's according to
the New York Times interview that Don
Lemon conducted last week with the vague
ramaswami played a role in his firing
note co-host Poppy Harlow said silently
while lemon goes after Vivek check this
out
is it gonna play fine I find your
explanation reductive and actually
insulting including to Black Americans
to say that black people today compared
to 1964 1865 haven't made progress in
part because of the freedoms we secured
and the Second Amendment please I cannot
keep a thought if you guys are talking
to me in my ear so hang on one second so
to say that yeah wait wait I got to
pause you hear that Don Lemon is talking
to the producers telling them to stop
talking to my ear they're probably
saying Don shut up up stop and he goes I
can't I can't do this and then he goes
off it's not the first time he's done
this black people secured their freedoms
after the Civil War is a historical fact
Don just study it only after their
second amendment rights were secured
that's not secured their freedoms after
the Civil War that is not your you are
discounting uh reconstruction you're
discounting a whole host of things that
happen after the Civil War when it comes
to African Americans including the whole
reason that the Civil Rights Movement
happened is because black people did not
secure their freedoms after the Civil
War and that things turned around people
were tried to change the freedoms that
we're supposed to you know how they got
it they got their second amendment
rights and they actually got the NRA
played a big role in that but today down
NRA did not play it absolutely
that's a lie that's not they already did
not play a big role this is just
historical facts the part that I find
because you say it's historical part
that I find insulting is when you say
today black Americans don't have those
rights after we have gone through that
civil rights revolution in this country
you are sitting here telling an
African-American about the rights and
what you find insulting about the the
way I live the skin I live in every day
here's where you and I have a great
point of black and white that black
people don't have in this country and
that black people do have well here's
where you and I have a different point
of view I think we should be able to
express our views regardless of the
color of our skin we should have this
debate without me regarding you as a
black man insulting that you're
regarding you as a fellow citizen here
whatever ethnicity you are explaining to
me whatever explaining whatever it is
yeah
[Laughter]
we should have this debate black white
doesn't matter I think we should have
the same content of the idea do it you
should do it in an honest way and in a
better way and what you're doing is not
an honest and fair we appreciate you
coming could you imagine buying a car
that's been just like stained with Don
lemon's crap I got it and then you're
like trying to convince people you're
making it better but dial lemon keeps
crapping in the front seat I gotta be
honest I am so sick of whatever
ethnicity you are privilege it is
whatever ethnicity you are wow no I just
want to be popular right now he went for
being racist without knowing what he's
not even knowing he's like he's like I
don't know what stereotype to insult you
with it's like I'm just gonna assume
there is something
so uh but I think the the real the real
reason I got fighters right there in the
beginning we'll play it again so with
due respect I find I find your
explanation reductive and actually
insulting including to Black Americans
to say that black people today compared
to 1964 1865 haven't made progress in
part because of the freedoms we secured
and the Second Amendment please I cannot
keep a thought if you guys are talking
to me in my ear so right there I cannot
to me in my ear CNN is so horribly
mismanaged I bet they were saying stop
arguing be a journalist stop arguing ask
him his views and move on and Don was
like no black lives matter if he asks
some questions he might know what
ethnicity he is that's right no no no
it's not about uh who's interviewing
it's about Don Lemon right he's here to
make these points whatever ethnicity you
are and move on I think that's what's
hard he is used to interviewing guests
who are maybe a little sycophantic he's
not prepared to not that Vivek is being
hostile they're just obviously a
different sides so he's not prepared to
go go into an interview with someone who
he disagrees with he wants people to
support his beliefs only and I think
that summarizes a lot of the hosts on
CNN and their viewership right it is
ultimately to reinforce your own world
be aware as like contrasting Tucker
Tucker was like look we got to talk
about this stuff that's happening even
if you don't like it or even if you're
skeptical about it Jeff Zucker
slithered into CNN
and then defecate into the brains of
their hosts because Don Lemon if you
watch his videos from like 10 years ago
was a very very different I was going to
bring that up if you just played a clip
of old Don Lemon versus new Don Lemon
completely different people completely
different like yeah Don Lemon I wouldn't
say mirrored Tucker but he he made good
points he was a normal human being he
actually seemed like he cared about
reporting and you know highlighting
issues that were actually affecting
people whereas now it's all propaganda
so uh this clip is just incredible we
love to see it we love to see people
imploding you know via their own actions
I just wish we could get the audio like
I wish to leak the audio of whatever
they were saying to Don Lemon like
please just move on don't say anything
don't don't do anything no it's a
producer being like Don please you need
to stop and then he goes I can't keep a
thought if you're talking about my ear
he goes I'm sorry or it was the
producers trying to like feed him
talking points to counter the fake yeah
you know what this is occurring to me
too so his network is most likely
getting mad at him for for being
annoying but it's not like he broke a
particular story that anyone is
speculating that they're mad at him for
anything that really says something
because with Tucker Carlson we are
speculating well maybe it was the
January 6th story maybe it was about the
Dominion voting systems whatever it
might be he stepped on a lot of toes
which theoretically is what a journalist
is supposed to do what story has Don
Lemon broke of any consequence that any
person in power oh would be upset about
oh uh he broke the story that he is a
black man who has personal experiences
that I think is wrong about see well I
didn't know that so thank you for
informing me now I have so much more
respect for his uh journalistic
abilities now that's right his lived
experience I mean couldn't figure out
whatever ethnicity that guy was his
lived experience yeah but he knew about
his own lived experience isn't that so
dismissive though to hold your own uh
ethnic or racial identity
as so important to you and then just
totally dismiss somebody else like
whatever you are I mean but that's the
entire modern day yeah it's either your
race your sexuality whatever makes you
the most special and then you just use
that to Discount anybody who disagrees
with your claims that's it so easy for
sure but if you're going to be race
obsessed at least be obsessed with my
actual race remember that whatever you
are is Sam I'm not from whatever you are
there was a phone call interview and
there was a black radio host it was like
a white woman and she was like well you
wouldn't understand because you're white
and he goes what ma'am I'm black and
she's like what he's like I'm black and
she's like you are like her whole world
view is just totally racist and she
couldn't understand that there are like
black people who have opinions and then
the weirdest thing these white liberals
who are like they they they can't fathom
someone like Candace Owens or Larry
Elder or Thomas Sowell those people must
be white supremacists or something like
they will not exist at all yeah people
tell me that I want to be white so bad
because I uh use my brain and I've done
research Regarding why our country is
where it is so uh that means I'm trying
to be a white person apparently yeah I
remember uh I told the story before
about when I was at the Dakota access
pipeline protest and I had a white dude
tell me that uh
Asian when he mentioned that being on
time for meetings was colonial thinking
no no that's what he told me and then I
was like what are you talking about it's
like I have a meeting I gotta leave and
he's like that's what the colonists
Native Americans they didn't do that
they just you know they knew when to
wake up and then I was like what are you
talking about Asians have us have have
schedules too like what what and he was
like yeah but let's be real like white
people brought that stuff to Asia and I
was like Asians invented the compass
1000 years before you did dude I'm not
gonna sit here and listen to a white
supremacist tell me he invented all
culture in the world but these people
genuinely believe it they like they're
white people who think they did
everything and anything good and like
stoic or work related or responsible is
they think it's just them and they must
bring it to all the lowly others exactly
well it's not just that right because
then they hate those things they hate
those good things and they also blame
white people for them at the same time
while taking credit for them so yeah
something like having schedules and
being on time that's why people think
like the ancient Egyptians had sundials
other cultures have had a concept of
linear time because it turns out like
people figured out pretty early on that
like one thing happens after another
thing and that you can figure out what
you're going to do based on what things
in nature do in their Cycles like where
the sun is at in the sky for example and
when we gotta harvest the grass to make
our beer yeah we started in uh like
North Africa Northeast Africa Let's uh
let's read this next story we'll jump
out of the cable new stuff and into the
boycott stuff we had this big story from
Breitbart Bud Light marketing executive
Daniel Blake on leave after Dylan
Mulvaney ad campaign ladies and
gentlemen two different Market
Executives have been placed on leave by
the company
you know what's really crazy instead of
just saying we're sorry they just
removed two people which is a huge
Victory I gotta be honest I'm happy to
hear it but they can't apologize
they put out a patriotic uh ad Tim that
that was it they have apologized what
else yeah like the next day and it was
like sidestep the entire I gotta I gotta
give a shout out to John Oliver who I
think is as dumb as a box of rocks but
had a good joke he was like I think it
was Oliver he said the commercial was
basically typing in America Freedom
Patriot sorry and that's what would come
out and I'm like it's actually pretty
good like that's that's basically what
they did and they they tried doing the
911 thing like insult to injury the
apparently they had this the Clydesdale
commercial after 9 11 with the bud or
whatever I don't remember that I mean
but uh so that's what they did in this
new one the Clydesdale is running and
then it runs past New York and there's
like those who never forget and it's
just like dude you're not you're not
getting out of that by saying 911.
please don't use uh
I mean we've downplayed 911 you know so
much might as well just throw it in the
bud light apparently so it's what you
need to do when you have to apologize to
what you don't like so I will say my
only thing I've said this before is that
both of these people are on leave they
are not actually fired a lot of people
view this as a step towards being fired
but I just think they'll put them in the
background for a little while they'll go
to the Bahamas they'll hang out and then
they'll come back they're hoping to keep
these people in place I think the first
lady got fired for hiring domovany and
the second guy got fired for that stupid
horse commercial
they were both placed on leave which is
ambiguous it means that like when you
guys are tired of being mad at us we'll
bring them back you know the other big
news today oh sorry go ahead I'm gonna
see the other big news that don't move
any hasn't posted anything since the
seventh that's interesting right Dylan
was posting almost every day or every
other day and just stopped posting when
this whole thing kicked off so I just
want to say like
I think Dylan Mulvaney is a person who
doesn't have anyone who cares about them
and that deeply worries me like anybody
who is in Dylan mulvani's life would be
saying stop this this is this is not
acceptable it's not okay they're being
driven by The Tick Tock algorithm into
like look Del Mulvaney came out an
interview and said how come no one's
messaging me to date like clearly the
machine is pushing Dylan in a direction
that regular people are not interested
in and the people who love and care
about Dylan or maybe there's nobody are
not doing anything to help Dylan with I
mean Mulvaney was even just interviewed
in that article where you know
she was talking about I don't think
domovania's Trends yeah yeah
sorry I don't know what we're allowed to
say here this isn't my YouTube channel
so I'm just trying to be extra safe here
well let me just say it real quick so
you can make your point Dylan Mulvaney
does not in my view I'm not I'm not a
doctor exhibit any of the traditional
gender dysphoria or a AGP or AAP which
is what is typically associated with uh
transgenderism publicly
Neil Mulvaney made a video singing about
looking at his bulge which is clearly
the opposite of AGP or gender dysphoria
it seems like Dylan Mulvaney is just
mocking trans people to get views
because the algorithm keeps promoting it
yeah I mean look I think when you have a
giant marketing firm that throws
somebody like this out into the public
eye the public absolutely has the right
to comment on it and the public
absolutely has to write to say what they
think is Despicable about it that said I
do feel bad I mean I I feel bad for him
because
this is someone who's clearly
got something wrong with them this is
not normal healthy behavior in general
well I I I I I I think I gotta say I
half agree okay but continue I'm not
saying that there's no agency there I'm
saying someone has something wrong with
them and you made this point about no
one being in their life who cares about
them I remember a long time ago
I had a friend who was watching uh some
of these American Idol cringe
compilations where someone who is really
bad at singing is intentionally selected
to be on the show so they can sing
poorly and the audience can laugh that's
how it works and that's yeah what he
said was I don't think these people have
anyone in their life who loves them and
that's essentially what we're seeing
they're not enough
Truth for the American Idol thing and
it's it's so many other facets of life
there are people who are they genuinely
think their friend can sing they're like
you're so good you should go yeah and
then they go and so I've had friends
who've tried it for American Idol and
when they explain to me the process they
were like oh like all the bad singers
you see half the time they're not even
in the room with the without with the
judges what they'll do is they'll record
the bad singers in front of a camera and
then they do a cut that makes it look
like the judges are in the same room but
they're not they're watching a video
screen of it so then I actually said but
sometimes they are and that means that
the producers go to the Bad scene and
say we want you to sing in front of the
judges it's intentionally done I think
for Dylan Mulvaney
you said there's something something
wrong with them
I don't necessarily I think it's I think
it's total agency I think what's what's
wrong with Dylan is narcissistic
personality disorder I think everything
that Dylan is doing is an active choice
to pretend to be trans and there's more
evidence to suggest that Dylan is Faking
It Ali London has produced previous
interviews and recordings showing that
Don mulvania has lied about when he was
transitioning and other trans people
have come out on YouTube videos saying
Dylan is clearly not taking estrogen
despite saying on two different
occasions that he had started taking it
at two different times so not only does
he contradict himself but these other
trans YouTubers have said it doesn't
look like he's even taking estrogen at
all based on on his body it makes it
even more bizarre to me because Dylan
did undergo serious plastic surgery
right like I think they've explained it
no no no no that's been explained too
apparently I don't know if this is true
but people have pointed out that Dylan
did not get facial hair removal just
facial slimming which is not that can
easily is more easily reversed meaning
if Dylan ever decided just to go about
living not as a woman or whatever or
doing this publicly Dylan would very
quickly look male again I mean what if
this is over like this uh Bud Light or
Budweiser thing came out on as to Mark
365 days of girlhood right this one year
mark is when all of this happened what
if in another week Dylan comes out and
is like I tried it but you guys are so
hateful I'm just gonna go live as a man
and you guys are bigoted and terrible at
this point the corporations are taking
full advantage of him and I you know but
I don't want to touch him at this point
right but Tim brought up the point that
he hasn't posted in how what three weeks
since the seventh so so it's been a
while like you said he was consistently
posting but I what I view with this
whole entire thing is again corporations
taking advantage of mentally ill people
and I don't say that in you know like I
mean yeah in a disparaging way I'm not
trying to be hateful here when I say
that but yeah very clearly if you are
cross-dressing if you think that this is
how women behave if you think that this
is normal behavior in society and a lot
of people do because we've hyped it up
instead of telling people the truth
which is why you have all of those viral
clips of Matt Walsh and Michael Knowles
when they do speak to transgender people
because they're very clearly telling
them the truth and the transgender
Community can never argue their their
points properly as to what it does feel
like to be a woman I can't even explain
what it feels like like to be a woman
and I am a woman because it's not a
feeling it's something that you're born
with right you're either a man there's
no uh there's no reference point yeah
exactly and so this is just corporations
taking full advantage of uh easily
manipulated people Tim I was talking
with Hugh about the United Airlines
transgender that was platformed given
all of the affirmation put into an
advertisement and ended up all seeing
themselves because of I don't know
whatever pressure and you know I was
actually in front of scotus for the
trans day of Vengeance that got canceled
as well I was speaking to a transgender
woman who was basically saying oh yeah I
self-harm to get attention because I
want to be visible and that's why the
trans Community
um
I think this is one of the the big
issues with what we're seeing with Dylan
Mulvaney first that what I see in Del
Mulvaney is narcissistic sociopathy not
gender dysphoria one the the people who
are experiencing gender dysphoria
they're not doing what Don will then he
does dancing around in the woods in high
heels and singing look at my bulge over
and over again and keeping facial hair
and other things like that
what's happening is these big Tech
platforms like Jack Dorsey said all
those years ago were concerned about
suicide rates so they started offering
up social media protections for these
people which was then quickly exploited
by people who want fame and attention
but don't want to get any penalties so
let me explain it this way if you post
right wing memes on social media let's
say before Elon Musk bought Twitter you
were banned Carpe dongtum was banned and
broke no rules but you don't post those
memes
but if so how do you exploit human
emotion for clicks and Views and avoid
getting banned you do it from the left
the easiest path is exactly what Dylan
Mulvaney is doing the algorithm proves
it when you look at Dylan's earliest
content it was animals it was Dylan on
The Price is Right and then when Dylan
made a trans video boom that's when he
started getting traffic started getting
Fame and he chased after it well
remember the video too that came out
where he was like oh I can't find any
rules as uh I can't even remember what
he said but he was basically like oh my
friend wrote a role for me as a more
like trans feminine person and you know
again like he has been trying to adhere
to this he did find Fame in this and it
does seem like he has stuck to this and
he is really uh you know taking it as
far as he can yeah I think the issue
with that was that uh Dylan had
previously said
that they were trans deleted the video
and then later once again came out as
trans like the whole thing was staged as
like it was a fake coming out I guess
one thing I'll say about this is that I
don't even like being exposed to this
the fact that kids are exposed to this
is what bothers me that's Tick Tock the
most yeah so do we ban tick tock
I so the legislation that Republicans
were pushing to ban Tick Tock from what
I understand did some other things that
we might not be in love with but I think
that there is a real question to explore
there about banning Tech I I would not
be against it on principle you'd but
you'd have to show me good legislation
yes I really important I think the
legislation is yeah how do we do it as
the issue but I think it is a good idea
I would I think we should yeah but you
you would have to give me something that
really will expand it instead of lying
to me if we look at what Tick Tock
really is it's China subverting our
country that is what it is point blank
again you guys have talked about this
multiple times uh what are the children
in China targeted with on Tick Tock
versus the children in the United States
of America it's like night and day so it
is
they don't actually have Tick Tock and
China they have something similar called
something else and it does but owned by
the same company that owns Tech talk
right like I'm not entirely sure maybe
maybe I just know that there aren't all
companies in China basically controlled
by the CCP anyway so it's
between like November and Germany this
wave of like 25 Governors who were like
you are not allowed to have tick tock on
a state-owned device because part of the
user agreement is that it can collect
all this data including whatever else
you have on your computer like your
browsing data and things like that so
like if you are a government employee
and you have some sort of like someone
who works at the DMV right and they're
pulling up whatever and then they decide
to watch tick tock on their computer
like they have now exposed your data to
this this company that has to report
data to the the CCP under a 2017
National Intelligence law yeah like I
don't really think that we need this and
I know people say like oh Free Speech
things like that like build a competitor
have something else like I'm not saying
you can't say the things that you say on
Tick Tock I just don't want that
technology uh that is serving a
different entity it's not serving the
people of the United States in the
country yeah well also freedom of speech
does not mean that foreign adversaries
are able to collect data on all of your
intelligence officials and your
government and your citizens but see the
problem is our own corrupt government
that is instead of fixing the subversion
by the Chinese problem is instead saying
here's the Patriot Act 2.0 we are going
to instead fix this problem use it to
further come down on your constitutional
right so classic government once again
let's talk about things that uh we can
do let me pull up the story from the New
York Post Bud Light suffers staggering
17 sales plunge amid Dylan Mulvaney
controversy the latest sales data from
Nielsen IQ and bump Williams Consulting
show the Bud Light sales fell 17 percent
of dollars while volume dropped a
whopping 21 percent
wow wow wow yo this has got some
feathers uh ruffled up that's huge
YouTube started taking down videos and
this is what I said my opinion on the
matter opinion is that the the sales
decline was bad and Anheuser-Busch got
angry and went to YouTube and said why
are we advertising on your platform if
it is loaded with people ragging on us
and so they they I think Bud Light was
like take these videos down YouTube took
down what they could they didn't issue
any strikes on channels why that would
cost them even more money I think
well I think we're gonna see that in the
next report it's going to be comparable
in terms of sale the sales Decline and
then it will it will uh the sales
decline will reduce so let me explain
in the first week when sales declined it
was like I think eight percent or
something so if they've got a hundred
let's just do the hypothetical number
100 units of beer sold this week drops
by eight percent now it's 92. next week
it goes from 90 to to let's just say I
don't know 81. and they report the drop
now is 10 but it's still around the same
amount of beers a little bit more what's
going to happen is if they declined by
21 beers this past week when the same
number of beers decline it's a it's
going to be a actually I think I got the
math wrong my point is it's going to
look like the decline is is easing off
because the boycott will reach a point
that it's enough of the market share has
been removed if 20 of people no longer
buy beer then Bud light's market cap
will drop by 20 and stay there and once
it stabilizes 20 lower it they will say
the the boy cuts over the decline in
sales has ended despite the fact what
really happened is no one is coming back
to buy their beer yeah right
know what I will say too I actually am
proud of the right wing for you know
staking it Sennheiser Bush and actually
sending this message because typically
in the past I feel like we get angry
about things but we're internet Warriors
and that's about it so I mean seeing the
pushback on this uh has been great and
uh I think it has sent a message to a
lot of other corporations as well and
they're going to start being more
careful about uh what they're
advertising yeah so I actually did a
cartoon about this a while ago called
what the media thinks right Wingers are
versus what they actually are and the
joke we were basically making with it
you know can go feel free to check that
out Freedom Tunes so the point we're
making with the video is they paint
conservatives out to be this highly
motivated Terror threat when
conservatives can't even get people to
boycott things yeah it's like yes I'm
going to give my life in a fiery Blaze
to commit an act of Terror and then it's
like hey how about we like don't eat the
cupcake brand that just issued a
commercial which was just two dudes
making out it's like but I like the
cupcakes and then we see with this
fortunately my expectations being
subverted and conservatives actually
doing something I think part of it I
mean I wonder if part of it is that so
many people who identify as you know as
uh their former marketing person said
like as the fratty humored kind of
Regular Guy felt not only isolated from
this but then attacked right you're
saying I am wrong for not supporting
this I think that is uh isolating its
base in a way that doesn't make any
sense I think it's harder for
conservatives to find a unifying product
to boycott right like maybe I don't buy
the cupcakes already like this was
something that people who probably felt
specifically attacked were like I'm done
but I think that they felt attacked I
think that this is like the sports issue
where men are like we don't give a damn
about this to be quite honest stop
trying to come in with the lgbtq
nonsense I'm just trying to watch the
NFL I'm just trying to drink a beer why
is this buying NFL tickets like they
still go yeah because they like sports
right yeah check us out check this out
uh so for for anyone who's claiming it's
not true Bud light's competitors are
going up while Bud Light Lost 6.7 of
market share last week Coors and Miller
Lite are up 18 according to the
newsletter a week earlier Coors Light
market share was up 10.6 over the same
period Miller Light was up 11.5 I just
I'd love to see it
um shout out to Jesse Kelly because we
mentioned this every time we bring the
story up he said it's the first time his
neighbors ask him about politics the
Dylan Mulvaney thing I think there might
be something to it where you've got
dudes who feel uncool to buy Bud Light
at this point and so let's break this
down in terms of marketing terms let's
pull out our politics the sponsorship of
Dylan Mulvaney created the perception
that the beer was for young effeminate
men so already you've got this Trope
where if you're drinking Bud Light
you're not manly I mean I I don't know
about you guys but back in Chicago if
you went to a bar with your friends in
order to Bud Light they would laugh yeah
I was gonna say I felt like that
perception was already there but I guess
they'd punch you in the back of the head
because you ordered they would be like
Bud Light was for when you're just
trying to get drunk at a party nobody
cared but if you were actually going to
have a beer to hang out at the game
they'd be like you bought Bud Light like
dude get Modelo at least I mean it's an
another bush people get like a real beer
get out get a Heineken or get Stella or
something but Bud Light so now you've
got dudes who are going to show up to
the party and they'll be like I don't
want to it's gonna be embarrassing
they've basically made it embarrassing
for men to drink beer with this
marketing campaign I think it's funny
too because the boys always love banding
together over stuff that they deem gay
not saying you know I just I think that
this is crazy it's 40 year old men who
don't want to look gay yeah in the
literal sense they they don't want to be
viewed as weak or effeminine yeah I
don't drink Bud Light or anything well
they don't want to subtly signal they're
like affiliated with this in any way
right and now if you offered someone who
came to your home like if you have a
co-worker inviting over you don't know
them well you're like can I have give
you a Bud Light like this is no one
wants to be here this is the meme
they've created this is the meme Bud
Light created with sponsoring Dylan
mulvania guys like you are already
seeing the left Champion Bud Light and
the right say Bud light's bad so what's
going to happen is you are going to have
people at Pride parades cracking Bud
Light and it's it's a it's a Whirlpool
for for Anheuser-Busch There Is No
Escape for what you have done to your
brand the left Will Champion Bud Light
it will be the the markings of great gay
pride parades of Pride nights and
conservatives and regular people are
going to be like I don't I don't want to
do all that so they went from being a
generic alcohol get drunk beer to a
leftist activist political brand that
people aren't going to want to associate
with I will say I don't drink beer
really but I hit a point where I was
like I have to know how to order like I
have to have a brand name to say when
somebody says do you want a beer and I
pretty much always uh order yinglings
because I know they donated to Donald
Trump but no here we go I'm not enough
of an acquired taste to be able to
scrutinize it I don't know if it's good
or bad beer it's fine and it does it
immediately like I don't I know that I
am supporting a cause that I'm at least
pretty much okay with right like I
wouldn't buy these beers because now
it's affiliated with a whole
conversation I don't want to be a part
of yeah if I if I'm getting like a cheap
light beer then Yingling's my go-to for
that exact reason but is England really
light it's not really that light well to
me it is why were you like holding
English or like Guinness well well
I just want this summer to be like the
summer of the small Brewery like
everyone's like I can't buy Bud Light
okay I'm going to get that like one
that's on the corner and my friends
buddy bottles it I ordered I think I
ordered while we were live 600 cans of
conservative dad's Ultra Rite Beer nice
nice that's what it's called okay
no no it's Seth weathers he put a put a
video on on Twitter where he smashed a
Bud Light with a baseball bat and said
and said stay the F away from our kids
we've just been like this beers filled
with testosterone
I remember yeah I don't know who again
it was a stupid marketing campaign
because remember it's also not like like
you said because Bud Light went from a
kind of meaningless name you know I just
want something cheap into like this is
no one was like yeah that's my brand of
beer it's like I remember way that's why
their sales are dropping there's no
loyalty Bud Light exactly well you
exactly if exactly
um
I'm sorry to cut you off but I feel like
it's a woman interrupted I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm using my privilege to speak
over you I feel like in hockey culture
Bud Light is a big thing but also take a
peek at in what who is pushing Back
Against The Pride nights right now it's
hockey players yeah specifically so Bud
Light is big in hockey but I think he's
also the most outspoken against the
lgbtq and a lot of places like the
hockey room is just like a sports arena
they just put down the ice you know
that's how it is in Dallas uh I think
that is what I'm finding most
interesting because when they're saying
the volume like what people are ordering
going down it means that uh certain
restaurants or like venues or whatever
no they are not going to be able to sell
stuff so they're not even going to order
it yeah and that's pretty crazy but it
makes sense because why would you waste
your money on it well and so I guess my
point was just that I used to see it
like okay you have the very very low
tier where you're dealing with like
Rolling Rock and Keystone and then
slightly above that is sort of where Bud
Light is but not Bud light's just below
all of it for me I'm never ever drinking
it again I mean
look I wouldn't drink Bud Light I
understand like I'm not gonna drink
Coors Light or Miller Lite or Miller or
Budweiser I've just always viewed them
as like generic garbage beers what do
you think you are I'm already seeing the
videos on Instagram too because I don't
have Tick Tock but I'll see like the
tick tocks that get posted on Instagram
of men like doing Blind beer taste tests
and they drink all of them and they
guess them and then they get to Bud
Light they talk in this like really a
feminine yeah that's hilarious they're
getting like millions of likes wow
really yeah it's they destroyed their
brand they really did people are making
fun of it all the time and it's all
these men like uh they drink a Bud Light
and they're they immediately and it's
just it's hilarious dude and and so
look the question is is anyone going to
want to sponsor Dylan Mulvaney after
this this is the algorithmic mistake
these are Dylan Mulvaney's popularity is
completely rooted in a robot randomly
choosing dull Mulvaney videos to show
the big Brands then saying this gets
views sponsor it and now their brand is
ruined I think they will because there's
a lot of Brands like Nike which
conservatives were so mad at Donald
Mulvaney for having this you know about
Colin Kaepernick yeah because we tried
to boycott them once upon a time
about uh you know Nike enslaving
children and then using the child labor
for to make you know their products but
Dylan Mulvaney is why we're mad at Nike
it's like conservatives have the memory
of a goldfish I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna lie to you guys but anyways the
companies that are already all in on Dei
and are already woke and know that
they're
I I guess their customer base is going
to be more behind them because they're
supporting a Dylan Mulvaney type who's
been demonized by the evil right wing I
could see that I think instead of small
Brands no yeah no of course not small
well small Brands wait no big brand is
going to do it no I think it's literally
sorry I think it's literally all gonna
be what you said which is these these
brands that have carved themselves out
in the market as a progressive option
they're gonna go can you believe how
people treat it that poor Dylan that
sweet Angelic soul and they'll put him
all over their branding and then they'll
be the the yeah
people are saying to boycott Maybelline
and Nike and all that stuff and it
doesn't work the same way yeah because
women want to look like Dylan Mulvaney
no no no
but hold on
if I was wrong women would be boycotting
all these products but they're not no so
so hold on hold on so I'm gonna make
sure I tell all of these feminists who
are defending Nike and Budweiser I'm
gonna tell them well you know what I you
do look a lot like Dylan Mulvaney so you
know it must be look and if they're
insulted by that that is on that's my
point they're a transphobe I think part
of it my point is this they're not
offended they have a man you see the ad
campaign of the guy wearing bra a bra
and panties no gosh that was horrible
it's it's a man wearing a bra and it's a
company's like they announced they're
gonna make bras for males and then all
these women are like they're like men
don't need bras though like men don't
need bras like they don't have boobs but
they're doing it anyway women
overwhelmingly are more in favor of
these political views in these things
yeah because we're more emotions
so it may be that that conservative
women don't want to look like Dylan any
and it may be that privately these
liberal men don't want to look like
Dylan Mulvaney but they clearly really
do resonate and support Dylan so I think
it's a compliment to tell them they do
look like Dylan Mulvaney well you know
that liberal women lie to themselves and
uh that's their entire Persona so of
course they would say yeah I want to
look like Dylan Mulvaney and it's virtue
signaling right like they want to seem
like they're the most can't accept it I
feel like I'm a Dylan Mulvaney
accelerationist though because the
feminists are starting to get pissed off
now and I'm like yeah accelerate go into
our bathrooms take over our Sports how
bad does it need to get and it is
getting bad and people are finally
waking up but it does take the average
person being personally affected which
maybe there were a lot of Bud Light
Drinkers and that was them being
personally affected and that's why it
was such a big campaign but yeah it does
need to get worse so I'm kind of a
Mulvaney accelerationist to be quite
honest with you it's very bizarre like
because of feminism and because of the
disunity between the Sexes we see as a
result of quote-unquote sexual
Liberation women are taught by this
culture to be relentlessly criticized
critical and of men until that man puts
a dress on and then you just have to
gush about everything they do and you
see this you guys were mentioning
earlier they want to claim that they see
this person as pretty but they don't
just say pretty it's the most beautiful
woman I've ever seen and they're all
over the top and losing their minds over
how beautiful they are and you can tell
exactly it's like this is clearly so put
on so but hold on like
is there something to women wanting to
submit yeah it's almost is that the
argument you're making is it built into
the female nature or something yeah I
think what I'm saying is that the
argument is yeah no there is women are
saying to two men you two men are more
beautiful than us are better at sports
than us and it's okay and acceptable
it's not a submission thing it's a fact
that women as a whole are not naturally
combative so if a man come a man comes
into the space and says I'm a woman now
I'm better than you and I'm going to
take away your rights by the way and if
you combat me you're a bigot and you're
getting canceled the average woman is
not going to push back they're going to
be like oh yeah uh okay but no that's
right but yes exactly it should not be
exactly to not be combative is to be
more naturally submissive yeah I think
that's part of it I also think that
because women are more emotional and
they're guided to do things like it
makes me think about like I don't think
this happens to Middle towards or middle
school boys at all but girls are like
don't gang up on other girls be nice to
them like be inclusive because they go
through really terrible catty phase is
part of their neurological development
but it means that when Dylan Mulvaney is
like I'm a girl women are conditioned to
be like great like we'll we're supposed
to be nice and accept you we're supposed
to tolerate this we're supposed to be
welcoming and inclusive like these sort
of uh Progressive emotional appeals
really reach women because women are
already conditioned to live in a more
emotional placement which can be
beneficial to society but in this case
it's basically them getting taken
advantage of right they are being
manipulated by this person who does not
have
true ties to their community and they
are not willing to oust him oh my God I
scared you I'm sorry that was okay I'm
glad she is about dilemma I know she's
so hungry I shocked the UFO out of
circulation oh well I think part of what
happens too is women want to support
femininity and they're confused about
exactly what's going on if I cheer on
the trans movement am I supporting
femininity or am I or am I supporting
men taking things that are meant for
women and that's sort of where the
delineation is between most feminists
and then what they call terms but it
could just be that women tend to be more
collectivist than men they absolutely
are look at the fat acceptance movement
I went to Victoria's Secret the other
day there was a morbidly obese model
modeling the underwear up front and it's
like okay why are we platforming
somebody who's clearly unhealthy have
you ever body right have you ever seen
one of those advertisements where
they're like any type of body and then
you go to look at the back and you're
like I don't think I want to buy this
thing because it doesn't look good like
there is a reason that you pick
Attractive people to model clothing it
makes you think oh this might look nice
like I can't tell if this looks good at
all because this person is not in it's
all politics nowadays though right so
Bud Light went political and they've
just turned their brand into the
left-wing brand and now people on the
right don't want to buy it well it's
it's it's
complicated though because one thing
I've noticed with women in this culture
and with just the Fallen human nature
you know men and women are different we
have different strengths and weaknesses
and one thing you see with women and I
don't know if this is cultural or if
this is biological but they often will
scorn other women for making choices
that help them to better themselves and
they will cheer other women on when they
do things that are self-destructive
absolutely so when a woman posts exactly
a woman post I've been working out I
look better than I ever look I've looked
in my entire life and especially if she
says she's doing this to make her
husband happy she is torn to shreds but
when a woman says I am sleeping around
and getting as out of shape as possible
because who cares and just choosing the
immediate short term there's going to be
so many women in the comment section
clapping for her whereas they tear down
women who are trying to build themselves
up it's a very sad thing I don't think
it's who cares it's because I love
myself I want to live this way I want to
live under self-indulgent I personally
feel like it's not necessarily I think
that it's it's a generational issue and
I think this is what happens when third
wave feminism opened the door to being
like women need to compete with men in a
platform in a lot of ways that aren't
healthy them like the reason the
transgender movement uh is
overwhelmingly the appeal is towards
women is because they're saying like
after so many years of saying like you
have the same quality as men so
therefore you should get to be in the
workforce we are saying the same thing
we have the same qualities women so let
us into your bathroom we'll see and I
think one of the best points that
continues to drive this home is the fact
that men are not dealing with women in
New spaces taking over their spaces and
again that does go into our gender role
that does go into emotionally and
biologically just how women respond to
things we are more easily manipulated
that's been seen time and time again and
uh on top of that like add to the point
that we are a culture that is already
you know via the education system
trained to be subservient trained to
listen to the authorities when you have
corporate corporations politicians the
entire higher government backing
transgenderism and saying that if you
come out against it that you're a
horrible awful person that you're a bad
Christian you even have churches coming
forward now and uh you know pushing this
ideology that is inherently
anti-biblical like twisting their own
theology exactly or just throwing it out
and then the average woman just goes
along and says okay well I don't want to
be combative of this and you know like
you said we also have a lack of strong
men in society that are willing to put
women in their place and that might be
like a very you know uh Brash thing to
say but I think that's where we're at
right now I just agree with this there's
tons of strong men that are willing to
put women in their place and they're on
the left
these corporate executives are telling
women what's alike and what to buy and
the men are saying yes and they're
buying it and they tend to be male
Executives and the right look I'll tell
you this
we have women come on the show and they
will conservative women will say repeal
the 19th Amendment where do you stand
Hannah repealing Ninth Amendment I'd be
for it but I don't trust the men in this
generation so it's it's hard to say uh
I'm sort of into having you on removing
women's rights I've looked at the
demographics and I if I had to give up
my one vote to 100 Psychopathic
emotional manipulative manipulated women
couldn't vote than I would yeah and it's
always the conservative guys who go no
no women should vote women should vote
you see my point is on the right the
guys are saying women can choose what
they want to choose on the left they're
saying look at this picture of a man in
in abroad that's what women should look
like and women go okay well but I I
think let me analogize this further all
right it's that the men are abdicating
and then the women are speaking to the
serpent right and this is this goes back
to Genesis the serpent didn't go to Adam
it went to Eve and Adam abdicated by not
saying why is my wife talking to a snake
and so that's what we see where they
they are telling women to do something
that will not make women happy and to do
things that won't make them happy but
and then men aren't there to say don't
listen to that idiot and then don't do
that afterwards Eve made that that Tick
Tock about being in the polycule with a
snake stop it
no I think it's right though I think
it's not just even men like I think
women could be more honest with each
other right if you didn't comment on
that video oh my gosh you look amazing
yay like you would not be contributing
to this group delusion that we're all
entering into right and I want to
clarify too about my uh put women in
their place I thought it was great I I
think that like you said if you have a
group of women women and you have one
man that comes in and says no that's
dumb that's stupid the entire group of
women is going to be like oh is it is it
stupid you know I worked in an
all-female office once we had to
interview for a new candidate it and
someone was like oh guys we've got these
resumes and maybe we should interview
this man and the head of the office was
like no we don't want to interview man I
don't want a man here because he was
like chaotic it's terrible working in
all female office yeah I could imagine I
think if the man was attractive the
woman might behave that way if the if a
thousand percent if the women were of
the collective opinion the man was
desirable they would be competing for
him and if they're of the collective
opinion the demand is undesirable they
would be like oh no I'm not gonna listen
to that guy I think women more so do
things for themselves than they do for
men right like the saying is women wear
makeup for women not for men women get
dressed up for women not for men there's
that famous tweet where a woman said
male privilege is being able to wear the
same clothes every day without anyone
criticizing you and a guy responded with
that's that's women criticizing you
literally no man cares if you wear the
same cute dress twice ever ever right
literally women doing all of this for
other women not for men the only kind of
man who cares is like generally not
attracted to women and you see that a
lot they talk about the the unfair
um the unfair standards that the fashion
industry places on it's like yes the
fashion industry notorious for just
testosterone-filled heterosexual men
being in control of everything and all
of the fashion trends of course yeah
yeah so I I think when it comes to the
guy who who comes in and says something
the real question is that the guy it's
whether the women agree among themselves
that the guy is an authority or isn't an
authority is attractive or isn't
attractive so if they respect him and
find him interesting like if if a
chiseled six foot three guy came in and
and the and the women all were just like
he is bad for this reason then they
would be like ew no yeah I agree he's
bad and if he was really nasty and ugly
this is this is why left-wing guys are
the way they are right when guys are the
way they are I well I would add
something else though I think that if a
man is really disciplined the women will
respect him for it and that's something
people Miss it's not just about like
height or appearance or weight there's
something too okay this is someone I
actually know can get things done and
Lead Me
I I I don't know if I agree completely I
think social pressure is the biggest
factor for for most humans on most
things men tend to be more disagreeable
and me that's going to result in them
being more individualists and women tend
to be more agreeable meaning they're
going to be more collectivists I think I
think but that makes it so sorry hold on
this is hold on a second we'll talk
about male female Dynamics and you're
trying to interrupt me here I would just
say yes explain women to me no yes I'm
going to there is an inbuilt social
pressure there's social pressure but
there's an inbuilt social pressure and
what a lot of people don't recognize is
that Authority is not external it's
actually built into human beings we have
a desire based on our biology and innate
understanding that certain people are
supposed to be in charge in certain
situations and we look for different
traits that would indicate that that
person should be in charge in any given
context and so women will look to men to
make decisions or be the authority on
things very often right I also think if
you have uh an unmarried woman who's
like life revolves around her Social
Circle so her friends in order to get
her to move away from that into marriage
and whatever else she has to really
trust you and respect you like the
things that women need to leave the
social Collective are a strong uh secure
man who they can rely on they won't do
it otherwise that's why we have a lot of
dysfunctional relationships because
they're people in relationships where
there's not a balance of uh dad's a
stay-at-home dad and the mom is bringing
home the bacon or well it's it's
oftentimes I mean yes that is that is a
particularly uh let's call it
interesting subversion but what happens
a lot of the time is women will end up
usurping without being able to abdicate
so they will take on male uh male
privileges but also male
responsibilities without like losing the
female responsibilities so she's still
very much going to be the one dealing
with the children and that's because
innately women are biologically better
predisposed to deal with children like
they can actually help feed and they can
feed them with their body so the idea
that we're just gonna to do this
swaparoo where in our relationship it
works for him to do the more feminine
things and me to do the more masculine
things no you're still going to get
stuck doing the feminine things because
he literally can't do those and you
can't do the masculine things as well as
you think either like carrying bricks
and stuff exactly exactly like email
marketing and fire firing and fighting
bears fighting bears you do need to be
able to do that yeah you know back in
the day you did you did nowadays I think
the point we're making here though is
that uh again just the subversion of the
gender roles and the complete
destruction of those have created such
just an unsatisfactory Society for
everybody involved and that's why
everything is in such disarray because I
feel like we have gotten so far away
from from morals from values from just
being normal people to be quite honest
to put it plainly go ahead I'll let you
go this time thank you so much for the
permission to speak Sheamus I am so glad
that you're here I definitely don't
you're welcome no I mean I think part of
it is uh we're asking everyone to go
against their natural inclinations and
instincts right and so no wonder by the
end of this and like I said I think it's
generational I think this has been a
pressure cooker for a long time by then
people are like I don't even really
think I'm supposed to be the gender that
I was born into because how do I know
I'm supposed to feel anything like all
of my instincts are probably wrong and
they can't see the Nuance between like
you'll hear so often like well our son
was really interested in his sisters
Barbies maybe just like hanging out with
his sister it doesn't mean it that like
he's a child doesn't mean anything and
instead we've made it like we're
constantly looking for signs that people
are outside they're different and we
accept them anyways instead of saying
like you're normal and that's actually
awesome I'm so happy that you know
you're normal you know what I realized
though in the age of social media uh I I
honestly think that the transgender and
lgbtq craze is the direct result of the
fact that anybody can get attention on
social media nowadays it's very easy so
now you have to go to much more extreme
lengths to get more attention and to be
more famous and to be on the top and
that's why we've also gotten to the
point where we've gotten to because
people continue to feel the need to
compete with who's the coolest who's the
most unique who's the most extreme yeah
I think I need to stand out and I will
do anything to do it yeah I think it
goes even deeper than that though the
first thing I want to say is relevant to
the the comment you made about people
being punished for being natural I've
noticed this so often when someone calls
something boost or red pilled it's just
someone saying something normal it's
literally just somebody's saying
something
yeah the scroll cook dinner for her
husband that's so basis like that's just
normal if that makes you happy I'm glad
but let's just get it normal but uh
beyond that with what you said social
media is exacerbated but I think it goes
much deeper the Advent of reliable
methods of artificial contraceptive have
completely changed Society in ways that
no one is willing to discuss or account
for because that's an innovation we're
not allowed to criticize but once we
removed the purpose of sex from sex then
the purpose of sex itself I.E your
biological identity also stopped having
a purpose and started being about you
just the way that sex has so my
biological sex exists for me and my
pleasure so why can't it be whatever I
want it to be why does it have to fit
into a specific role why does there have
to be a logos to it it's a complete and
total self-indulgence culture exactly
indeed I think uh we've got we've got
some stories from the members only
section and we should carry on that
conversation there because there's a lot
more to be said but uh probably better
off doing that in the not so
family-friendly version of the show so
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button and become a
member at timcast.com so that at about
10 10 pm we'll do that members only show
and uh if you sign up at the 25 level or
at least or you're sign up for at least
six months you can actually call into
the show but we're gonna go to super
chats right now so smash that like
button we're gonna read what you guys
have to say so before the show started
we got a super chat from Leon Yoder who
said the special guest is Sheamus
Coughlin uh there was a couple other
people who tweeted when I tweeted we
have a special guest tonight someone was
like it better be Sheamus Coughlin but
everybody was like Tucker Elon
yeah you know I'm sorry to disappoint
you all yeah I was the best I told
Allison I was like they're gonna be so
disappointed Tim's like dude people I
just way over hyped you're really gonna
have to perform I was like you're such a
you're such a good friend Tim thank you
Charlie duck says what a crazy day I
can't believe what's going on it is a
really crazy day like the whole day was
just nuts like I in my 1pm segment I'm
reading I'm like Tucker Carlson is fired
and then I get a notification right here
on the screen from The Newsroom saying
Don Lemon fired and I was like and I was
laughing live ring I couldn't help it
I'm just like this is amazing look the
economy is getting really bad it's
getting laid off I think there was a CEO
of NBC that also got uh pushed out today
too and one of the white I heard about
that uh policy directors got pushed out
yes he's gonna fire for like 4 000
people or something it really is spring
cleaning that's what this is wow amazing
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim my guy yo
that was freaking hilarious on your 1pm
segment when you found out Lil buddy Don
Limon got fired hilarious good riddance
to him yeah I was like I was like I saw
the tweet from him because someone
posted and I was like no this can't be
real it was some like crudely made meme
picture and I'm like is this actually
we need verification and then we like I
said New York Times New York Post it's
like boom boom boom boom I'm like whoa
wow oh my gosh all right Mandalore the
mighty says Sheamus is better than
Tucker anyway
the left doesn't want you to know this
but Tucker Carlson while being excellent
is not nearly as good as shimcast it's a
it's a fact you're allowed to say it wow
you just heard Tucker Carlson you should
have shut my camera off while I said
that's what people could think of it I
do want to point out I can already tell
that our viewers today are like 30 40
more on average because you deceived
them because no because it was taken off
the air what else are they gonna watch
exactly yeah Tucker's gone yeah I've
been watching this the whole time no
offense to Tucker but Superior show no I
never said Tucker was coming the show
Sheamus you're my special guest I always
you've been gone for like a year we were
so desperate to have you back we put a
potato in the chair no I was I was like
what is that was a hate crap it was a
hate crime my friend texted me while I
was out for St Patrick's Day and he said
you're on Tim cast and I was like what
did they do and then it's just a potato
I looked I was like Tim cast is this
some kind of homage to me and I was like
oh no they're just insulting my people
on our special day it was it was St
Patrick's Day it's very funny but
despite bullying him he didn't come back
I'm allowed to uh put potatoes I think
Ian is also Irish we're all plastic
patties all right none of us are from
Ireland oh cool what whatever yeah
Joe Biden's not Irish because no one in
his family's drunk are in jail
that's what he said that is literally
what Joe Biden said come on Ireland was
like I don't want to go back and we're
like wait what then he went to Ireland
dude this man
I hope this is the thing it's like
all right those are those are jokes
you're allowed to make because the Irish
are white but they got to keep a mic out
of Joe Biden's hand on like Cinco de
Mayo or black history monthly he's gonna
destroy it Anderson Jill's had a couple
scuffles there right throw back to when
she calls us all tacos that was pretty
funny yeah did she really yeah in Texas
it was not good she went to Texas and
she she basically implied that like
Hispanic people were breakfast tacos or
something I don't know Hispanic people
got mad about it I was just like it's
kind of funny whatever it was funny but
it was also like both Biden's like stop
giving them any sort of public speaking
engagement difficult when you were the
first lady and president they worked
directions says fox has ruined
themselves now their late night Gutfeld
show is going to hurt too also it's
about time CNN fired that man well look
I do think Fox News is going to hurt
from this and I think it's going to
negatively impact a lot of their key
demo viewership substantially what's
happening is so so it's creating an
opportunity for shows like ours to
capture that audience because we have
similar conversations that Tucker has
Hannity does not but there are people
who probably turn on Tucker and then it
rolls over into Hannity I suspect we'll
see ratings drop across the board
because they did this well you know so
be it good for them
do they really think it's going to hurt
uh the guthold show though but I I
certainly think it does absolutely okay
like I said people turn on Fox news or
Tucker and let it roll you know do you
guys remember when Joe Biden said
Irish kids are just as selburn just as
intelligent as white kids I couldn't
believe that all right uh Alex says but
for real it should have changed the logo
to Tuck cast extra people
should be Sheamus and Prime Time 99 uh
so I reached out to Tucker Carlson's
people and I said we will if we have if
Tucker can come on the show we'll put up
a title card saying Tucker cast IRL he
said only if you fire Sheamus and Tim
said I won't do it and then that you
know they said absolutely we can have
him there in in in in an hour or so you
know and then I said of course Sheamus
will be here then they didn't respond
and then an hour later they got back to
me and said I'm sorry we're not
available and then wouldn't respond to
any more messages and I was just like oh
that's actually not what happened I said
tonight Tim said that Tucker was going
to be on I said but tonight's my big
night and I stomped my foot so I was
like all right I'll tell them another
time all right Daniel trinka says a b
inbev spending more on marketing for
other brands like Modelo and the
fighting Spirit trying to capture
anti-woke money from the uninformed
yep because I wonder how the sales are
for Modelo yo I like Modelo I love that
one yeah medell's good but but it's not
yeah but like but light sucks I've seen
enough of the infographics where it's
like it's not just Bud Light it's also
all of these that I think they're uh
fighting an uphill Camp battle I think
people are more aware than ever but of
course some will some will sneak through
well and this is what's important for
you to remember even though I think yes
a total boycott of Anheuser-Busch would
be great I certainly would advocate for
that and I'm not buying their products
anymore when people say boycotts don't
work because a parent brand only has
this sub brand and the rest aren't
effective what they're missing is a
boycott sends the message that the
consumers did not like that particular
behavior and so the parent brand knows
not to try that with their other brands
well it got Fox
yeah I mean that's gonna be the easiest
boycott of my life bro it's the only
thing I watched was Tucker was the only
thing I watched on Fox News
it's the summer of us watching Rumble
and going to local breweries to get beer
yeah when uh what have I ever done
differently when Luke's here he always
wants the Show raps he always goes and
watches Tucker Carlson he which he
digitally downloads or whatever live and
he was getting do you remember when we
were in the car together and this was
right after the Eminem thing and I kept
making I kept doing my Tucker
Impressions
were and Luke was getting so angry dude
I was riffing for like a half hour like
every every night when it got a little
quieter like the green m m is the most
attractive thing I've ever seen in my
life and then somebody was like stop it
man Tucker's great I was like I I love
Tucker too Luke but you gotta be able to
take the jokes and we were just riffing
on Tucker loving M M's and then that was
a good bit with Bernie oh thank you
that's so small yeah if you guys want to
watch that cartoon Tucker uh gets mad
about the M M's that was a fun one
Tucker cartoons are always fun and then
Ben Shapiro and it's Again by the oh my
gosh so Lucas talked we by the way the
the wonderful thing about Luke not being
on the show is you still get to hear all
of his opinions in the chat because he
sits there and cries the entire time
about the fact that I'm there instead of
him hey look you see that behind me you
see that behind me look at it is Luke in
the chair right now this is conquered
land my friend no longer Yours by the
way of a fan because you took down the
American flag I would never listen I
didn't touch anything but what I am
saying is to the wonderful incredible
fans who make these kinds of things if
anyone wants to just make a paper flag
and send that in potatoes for Sheamus
says Sheamus I came out of the potato
field to watch you glad you let us away
from the mean Luke to the Sea of
potatoes to the promised land of taters
I did do that and I appreciate the
credit thank you Luke doesn't even
doesn't even have the decency to Super
Chat no the regular chats and then
expects me to read well he's a baby girl
hey well when I super super chatted and
you didn't read it when Dr Paul was up
you said potato people have no souls
that's see what I mean it's like what is
potato people supposed to mean that's
that's some kind of dog whistle right
he's referring to is he is he wait a
minute when Luke says potato peoples
he's talking about
Irish people
oh I'm so much more upset with him than
I was before I thought he was saying
something else check us out uh powder PC
says Alex Jones called Tucker leaving uh
Fox months ago when they stopped him
from showing the j6 footage Alex Jones
was right again
well Steve Smith says I feel bad for Dan
bongino Fox is going to lean on him so
much in the future Dan bongino's not a
fox anymore yeah yeah he just left
recently right next week yeah and they
thought it was a result of the uh
Dominion lawsuit right or settlement is
that what it is a confirmation
all right owling dog design says you're
all wrong about the older crowd I'm
older been watching Tucker and Tim cast
at all for years I'm not aging out of my
opinions I canceled Fox News
subscription and paid media today
and paid media today I am
maybe there's a typo in there
um but we're not saying all older older
crowds the fact is Tucker's audience 3.3
million only about four or five hundred
thousand are in the key demographic
meaning you've got two and a half
million people who are older than 55 who
watch Tucker Carlson regularly
our audience is like 70 to 80 percent uh
was it 24 to 45 so and then we have some
like Teenage like 18 to 24 and then some
55 plus but it's mostly in the key demo
granted we don't get three million views
we you know we get I think we average
like half a million per day on the show
from like 300 and something on YouTube
and then 100 and something on the
podcast and then we get with the clips
like 800 to a million I think they made
it immediately they did it immediately
so as soon as they saw that they
canceled the Fox News description oh
immediately yeah I see what you're
saying Luke without super chatting had
the the gall to say Sheamus is the older
crowd he's 50. I'm way younger than you
hold on I just turned 28 he's 50. yeah
it looks like Luke's an old one Luke is
like in his 90s Luke is like literally
in his night he's an old man
Carl says with FOX NOW out of the way
you can get Tucker on timcast all we got
to do is if you know Tucker Carlson tell
him we want to have him on the show and
we'll we'll get him out here I mean uh
so my understanding is we reached out to
his people they said they talked to him
directly and put in the request and
that's all we can do is now uh go on the
show and beg and pray that Tucker will
Grace Us by appearing on the on the
podcast talk about a great show yeah
what if he comes out with Elon we'll
just have a double feature day jeez yeah
if Tucker was here that would be that
would be incredible so how do we get
Elon and Tucker to be on the same show
well they just did the interview
together I mean you know so maybe
they're on the phone right now deciding
they're waiting to be asked together
yeah you never know they could or maybe
they're like I will not do it or maybe
they're like I won't do it if Hannah
Claire is there that's for sure look I I
think I would be told you know take the
night off I don't think Tim would do
that to you I I respect the show enough
to say like if I have to give up my seat
for Tucker Carlson Elon Musk I'll do it
see we met about women being more
deferential this is
oh yeah
Sheamus actually threatened me with
violence that's right he said that's why
the you know that's how you get Victory
I'm sorry I can't unfortunately the the
United the American in military
industrial complex is on your side with
that one Sheamus but uh no no I think
we've got plenty of Suits here plenty of
seats we could easily peaceably
accommodate our good friends Elon and
Tucker all right what do we got here Rob
says Tim now is your chance to partner
up with some local distilleries that
have the same values as us and get your
and get your liquor license I'll create
an entire cocktail menu inspired by our
mutual beliefs of individual Freedom
Chris Carr did that yeah our
editor-in-chief head bartender yeah he
made a whole big culture War menu and
it's actually really good and uh you
should tweet at him and get his recipes
as for local Brewer breweries and uh
distilleries we've been talking to local
breweries and we're actually talking
with one about doing a signature uh Brew
but um we got to get the space up and
running we got to get a liquor license
and then we would have our own signature
beer
that'd be very cool
the what do you call it though we have
cast Brew Coffee what's the other one
cast brew beer you have to have a potato
man's lager or something uh is that I
that's permission to use your likeness
you said it live so no I take it back
Dr Seamus coughlin's oh dude we should
hear growth formula we should we should
combine you should combine fours with
freedom Tunes to have it be Dr Mack this
doctor is my news reporter who's
basically just my voice and he's I think
I think he's an Irish person I think
it's funny to have like Dr Coughlin it's
a picture of you in an old-timey suit
you know Dr coughlin's
hair growth time can I have a like a
monocle
yes perfect yeah
all right let's see Captain Caveman says
Tucker was obviously fired over the 787
million dollar Dominion settlement maybe
that may have been a component of it I'm
entirely sure though
a lot of things a lot of things
all right
Sterling Michael says any Millennials
realize that Trump is still
commander-in-chief by military law it's
public information if you know where to
look that's not true what first of all
go to
patriot.blogspot.wordpress.com and you
will see that he is literally still the
commander-in-chief yeah he's literally
not he's a private citizen no he's still
that's why January 6th was so horrible
because that's how he kept the power of
the military Tim it was an Insurrection
it was a right absence record that's
right well I mean the answer is in
charge now is that is that defamation I
mean look people are saying that ray-ups
might Sue Fox News but like he's on
video saying to go into the capital so
yeah well didn't they say everyone there
was an insurrectionist I don't
understand how you could say that he
isn't but he was the guy who was telling
people to do it no I know it was the
right absence Direction okay but what
I'm saying is yeah there was no direct
quote for Trump number said go on in do
it but this guy was telling people to go
into the capitol so yeah you're correct
if they're going to call it Trump's
Insurrection no it's right right Epson
no I know but I'm saying if they can get
away with calling it Trump's
Insurrection then I don't know how you
could see this one right now
yeah no exactly but the more they try to
push this like the more they prove I
don't I don't I don't think he's a fed
you don't think he's offended nope uh
and I think the FED it depends on your
definition of fed and I think that it's
they they set things up perfectly so
that they can sue you if you do
something like that you not so much I I
mean the rhetorical you like Fox News is
scared because what the feds will do is
they will contract an individual and
then if you accuse the person he's got
the full weight of an infinite backing
infinite cash Reserve to sue you into
Oblivion and destroy your career
interesting but we'll see you know they
did it to Alex Jones yeah we'll see what
happens with uh Fox News and um Ray apps
but that being said Luke just called me
a Fed in chat that's a lawsuit right
there that's a lawsuit first of all Luke
is big con right Luke is establishment
conservatism and I've been trying to
tell people from the start you should
see the contract he sent me
oh yeah yeah absolutely I'll I'll show
it expect a lengthy Twitter thread to
follow where you prove this there will
be there will be good yeah later Steve
Smith says Don Lemon will end up on ABC
News you know I honestly wouldn't doubt
that see but the way that he's talking
about getting fired I wonder if all the
networks are like we don't want him he's
too difficult to deal with I mean news
Nation picked up Cuomo sure
maybe maybe lemon has a you know a
future there Amish man says I remember
the timcast episode when Sheamus said he
couldn't do Tucker's Voice or Tim's
voice but he was practicing Tucker now
he's nailed it I can do talk before he's
perfectly I don't know if I can do Tim's
voice yet either have just can you do
Joe Rogan no Joe Rogan's voice is too
normal I can do his speech patterns kind
of Joe Rogan like pauses and talks like
the thing about that is this he totally
like he'll he'll be thinking and he
moves his arm like this
I've not seen anybody able to
impersonate Joe Rogan well his it's
because of like he has certain
mannerisms that are easy to pick up but
his voice is so unique that he's really
really hard to do an actual impression
it's very hard to do his voice I
definitely can't like Ben Shapiro Jordan
Peterson they're they're easy no they're
really hard so I only I can do them okay
Ben Shapiro does a great Joe Rogan
impression okay have you tried DMT again
honestly this is absolutely amazing I
saw that the elf people came and took me
to another realm Ben Shapiro
impersonating Jordan Peterson
impersonating Joe Rogan
it's like if you're not going to embody
the archetypal by taking DMT you're
never gonna kill the snake gang
all right all right you gotta watch Tim
Dillon's impersonated Joe Rogan that
one's actually it's good he does it he
does it it's good
Anna P says what if Tucker goes on CNN
also a member of Tim cast but on YouTube
it tells me to become a member any way
to combine it I use the same email no
they're uh two different things so
YouTube membership is something totally
different to the website membership and
there's no way to combine it
all right
Captain Cayman says internet killed The
Prime Time news start it certainly did
what do we get Publius Valerius says
Valeria says I support Tucker going to
work for CNN and Don working for Fox
might as well go full 1984 at this point
corporate media is a joke wow
John Curry says the only thing better
than having Tucker on is having Sheamus
back
thank you thank you better than having
to talk about it makes me feel pretty
good
yeah yeah it is why would did they say
anything to indicate that that was not
their honest opinion on it it's just
interesting that you're trusting you
believe them yeah well I think you
should give people the benefit of the
doubt no that's that's nice of you not
all of us walk through life like
skeptical cynics who doubt everything
they see in here must be so I just I
pulled the audience a very important
question oh boy should Sheamus give Tim
a non-fouchy role
oh well I have and I did on the last
video and you never sent me your
audience that wasn't fair I gave you the
police officer in the last video
one hour he's like I need you to voice
this police officer here read this and
I'm like I did it like 3 three days
ahead of time do it and you said
I was like you're not here I don't know
what you're asking and then Sheamus does
his quick voice memo and he's like just
say this and I'm like I said say it like
this I said say it like this you said I
need direction and I gave you the
direction he wanted me to come back
you've done that's yeah that's actually
what that was that was originally the
line in the video 78 said yes all right
well this is why this is why
was Dominion in charge of the Twitter
poll you just said I should voice Nancy
Pelosi oh I'm fine with you voicing
Nancy Pelosi I will get her in a video I
think be very funny why aren't you
writing for Tim's acting credentials
that's right that's the real question
listen
people on IMDb put Freedom tunes on my
IMDb I know I know you got well why
wouldn't they you're one of the voice
actors that's how it's why you're
notable I took a picture I posted it
yeah did you yeah it says it says you're
like I finally made it yeah my voice
actor I played Dr fauci on freedom Tunes
look I'll be honest there's millions of
views in these videos it's true there's
millions of views and I should get an
Academy Award or something well I
wouldn't go that far your performance
was okay can I get in Sag with that now
absolutely yeah
and what's the other one aftra what's
after for I don't know it's the same
thing isn't it no I don't I wouldn't
know sounds like an insurance company
all right uh Chinese by balloon says we
should start a GoFundMe for Don Lemon we
could call it Don lemonade that's I love
it I love it when life gives you Don
Lemon right like I already pitched he's
going in Academia but maybe he'll take
over some you know not very well-known
non-profit and rename it dot lemonade it
and just give out money I hope that
Meadows says I nominate Dan bongino to
take the 8 PM slot at Fox it's like man
did people not realize that they booted
that Dan majino was out he got fired
right yeah uh they couldn't they
couldn't reach an agreement on their
contract oh okay but maybe now that the
8pm slot is open Don is ready to come
back to the table yeah yeah that could
be possible
what do we got
Jesus Goblin how do you feel what how do
you feel like you're like what do we
have here in my chat my princess how
much money are you sending me sir Tim
how do you feel learning in our earned
this time slot no Tucker no more
competition
I actually had people texting me saying
like the 8 P.M time slot is yours and
I'm like
Tucker Carlson was getting three million
views he's getting like 10 times the
viewership that we were but you know
I'll take whatever trickles off of uh
his empty slot now I mean we got we got
a lot more viewers today so maybe uh
maybe Fox will you know hire you for
that slot and we'll just broadcast from
here
all right Paul Sakura says Sheamus who
in your opinion is the better
theological thinker and writer or who
has more influential in your
understanding of the Catholic faith
Saint Thomas Aquinas or Saint Augustine
okay that's a really good question so I
love me some Saint Augustine I really do
but I'm gonna have to go with Aquinas
smart Feller that guy yes yes extremely
intelligent I don't know enough about
either of them other than that smarter
than Luke for example other than who
isn't Aquinas is cited by even secular
individuals in terms of philosophy so
yeah exactly and scholarship I mean
sometimes I'm sure Augustine is
sometimes is well but I know that
Aquinas lays out the model for what a
scholar should be because he writes
everything starting like with his
opponent's arguments and the the best
arguments his opponents have and then
laying those out and just decimating all
of them violent hour says Gollum Tim
horrifies me that's very good that's
very good same I was not prepared for
that voice oh yeah that's very good when
are you gonna write that into Freedom
Tunes Tim as Gollum
it has to be like there has to be a
moment when a scraggly
um
it's got to be like a Democrat like
Schiff or kinzinger and they're trying
to get something and then we just have
them be Golem you know what I mean that
would make sense but the thing is like I
can do a gun voice too so you'd have to
it'd have to be better than mine
I just don't think so Sheamus is like oh
you're Starlet from Ash I go the face
give me that ring back boys
15 second monologue from both of you in
the gollum voices all right monologues
all right we're next episode we're each
gonna pick a famous monologue from a
move your TV show and then we have to
deliver it as Gollum and we'll see who's
his better we'll have people vote in and
that's the whole show wait to get one
hour
[Applause]
and then you can do uh Trump's rally in
uh San Jose it can't they can't both be
uh can't be both Trump I don't know you
want to have some control in this
experiment right I'm exactly I gotta
pick my own although there would be
something to be said of having uh uh
I'll get the Gettysburg Address a trump
rally after the 2020 election and having
uh
Gollum just say the stole it from us
[Laughter]
pounding machines I'm sorry I was gone
at the face of this whole day story I
stole it from myself oh my God this is
really a missed opportunity all around
all right where we got um
Captain Caveman says the recycling
center by my house is the sun says no
Bud Light accepted for Redemption
wow remember remember when uh beer
commercials were a bunch of like
scantily clad women and the message was
that if you drank their beer attractive
women would want to have sex with you
yeah remember the burgers more
degeneracy the what the burger
commercials that were like that too yeah
it was like they were trying to sell
things and they were like I know what
we'll get a guy to buy this sexy women
and you know what there's nothing women
love more than a man-eat a cheeseburger
that's that's like
yeah making the cheeseburger you know
that's right providing that's true all
right all right all right what do we
what do we got here like it's like
fixing your car and taking you to get a
cheeseburger you know yeah I don't wanna
have to Publius says I would buy Ultra
Maga beer someone please create that
brand uh Seth weather's made concert
conservatives dad Ultra right beer which
is similar Lords Lord spam says Yingling
makes a half Porter called Black and ten
it's wonderful the Irish have no excuse
Shameless what did you just say
Shameless wait wait hold on when did I
ever claim the Irish have any excuses
besides alcoholism that is an excuse
It's a disease it's a disease and the
various uh public ratings they get from
being targeted by politicians yeah
exactly it's not fair like Joe Biden
come on come on
project apario says Tim Andre here
inventor you can integrate the YouTube
API to timcast and pick up subscription
information from that ping me if you
want oh really we could probably figure
something out then we'll try and figure
something out
Let's see we got
no soup for Noel says still waiting for
the special guest
wow so nose firstly no soup for Knowles
is a voice actress who does the female
voices on freedom tune so I think she
got jealous of my Golem impression
because she knows she can't do one
that's nearly as good and I think she
wanted to hurt my feelings and that's
what we're seeing right now Raymond g
Stanley Jr says happy birthday to Olivia
Claire let's go
what you said it was your special day I
didn't say it was my I thought this was
like your Bromance special day well I
don't know I guess he was talking to you
also my name's not Olivia Claire yeah it
is
um correct I just renamed you okay I
can't believe you've known me for the
song you don't know my name no I don't
know exactly like Luke and he changed
everything oh okay that is you knew how
to try to get under my skin and I
appreciate that I love something a
little more manipulative and complex all
right understandable but it's not gonna
work because I know what you're trying
to do Calvin Shaw's uh indie game says
shimcast is back trying to remember
whether it was Noles or Fred it was
Knowles who called him a Shiite wahhabi
Catholic
oh he loves my Hollow ad thank you yeah
so we just got sponsored by this prayer
app called Hollow and the joke we do I'm
so glad they were okay with this app or
this ad and I'm so glad they liked it
but if you guys if you watch our last
video there's one at the end of it it's
I really recommend you check it out
um the last couple videos we did have
this hollow ad and it's super funny we
had Michael knowleson and Ian asked the
religious question and he was like you
really need to ask Sheamus that who is a
Shiite wahabi Catholic
that's so sweet of him thank you Michael
it's so sweet of him
uh what do we got
Trevor greens has published the same
cartoon twice one voicing Tim and one
voicing Sheamus and see which one gets
more views oh mine clearly would no I
wouldn't yeah because I would just tell
my people everyone to watch mine instead
of yours they would never do it yeah
they'd be alive they wouldn't it be like
did Washington go they'd throw like this
garbage and then they'd find mine ah
thank goodness a light in the darkness
yes it's exactly what they'd say
I really think there's only one way to
determine this I feel like you've gotta
move forward with this plan and
competition
it's got to be done
it's two Golems they both looked around
nervously I want that on Nancy Nancy
Pelosi and Adam Schiff arguing about
Trump but they're both in the voice of
Gollum acting like Gollum and Sheamus is
one on the other
or you should just do this show
regularly voices for as long as you can
we'll we'll do
um we'll literally just do like Joe
Biden quotes his Gollum
Justice brought and talented as red
Harvesters as fat ones
[Music]
foreign
oh my gosh uh that's yeah so uh Matt
says Tim voice for Lori Lightfoot
actually that's the Lori Lightfoot voice
that should be the Lori Lightfoot voice
we did a cartoon with her behind the
paywall but um I don't think we've done
one with her on the main Channel we we
gotta we got a story for you guys over
in the uncensored portion of the show so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
because apparently uh with Tucker out of
the way we are now going to be the
biggest show finally our the only thing
standing in our way Tucker Carlson has
been defeated and um that means the 8 PM
slots uh ours so you know Sheamus
welcome back yeah thank you and I gotta
say there's someone else gunning for
your job there's this really cool uh new
podcast on Rumble called shamer that
this this guy named Seamus Coggin said
it's like kind of a big deal and so part
of why I think part of I think
all right but the record show it was Tim
making poop noises that entire time
absolutely uh disgusting I think that
well something in this contract I'm
allowed to make poop noises during his
it's actually true when he reads dates
oh I shouldn't have signed that I
shouldn't have signed that but well so
we'll do that we'll only wrap up okay
yeah and then we're gonna do the
uncensored show in a few minutes so go
to timcast.com click join us become a
member join the Discord uh Discord
members can call into the show if
they've been a member for at least six
months or sign up for 25 bucks and uh we
got a lot more stuff to talk about so uh
Savannah did you want to shout anything
out uh yeah go follow me on YouTube Sev
says and Twitter same exact handle I'm
excited for the uh after hours show it's
where I can finally actually speak my
mind so go check it out guys I'm excited
not family friendly yes because she
usually keeps her opinions to herself I
really do I want you all to listen to me
very carefully I have a mission for you
I need you to go over to youtube.com
Freedom Tunes it's my cartoon channel
where I make animations I need you guys
to subscribe every Tuesday and Thursday
we upload a funny cartoon and we're
going to start uploading three a week on
occasion so yeah you guys are gonna love
it this guy's crazy I'm a Madman I'm a
free labor now I'm a big old crazy guy
over here and also someone in the chat
said this guy should have a daily
podcast I appreciate that I do have a
podcast it's twice a week it's on Rumble
rumble.com shamer and this week we are
broadcasting every single night 6 p.m
Eastern go over there check it out you
guys are gonna love it thank you so much
I'm so so glad to be back this went
incredibly well in spite of Tim's best
efforts it was wonderful chatting with
you all and I can't wait to see you the
wonderful audience on the after show
I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
you can also tweet at our executive
editor editor Chris Carr for his various
uh cocktail recipes if you want to
follow me personally you can follow me
on Instagram at Hannah claire.be and you
can follow me on Twitter at hcbrimo
thanks so much
and I am serge.com free Froggy Fresh I
hope you have a good night talk to you
guys later people are asking I guess
they didn't rumble.com shamer that's I
think they're saying no no I'm saying
like what's the channel
so uh follow the show at timcastirl on
Instagram and Facebook follow me
personally at timcast and we will see
you all over at timcast.com on the front
page in about 10 minutes